this is Jocko podcast number 356 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
Gettysburg was a great battle
it's action it's tension it's hazards
its consequences
in it were involved questions of gravest
import the decision of which makes
history
interests social political moral
personal
of gravest import for ourselves for
others for our country for man
everywhere
for the present time and for the future
for which also we hold a trust
the pressing question before us was
whether we had a country
whether we were a people
or only a populace
whether we were a mere chance
partnership only holding only by human
will or a nation constituted in the
purpose and calling of Divine Providence
bound together for the noblest ends of
living by ties of mutual interest and
honor
bonds both of love and law
all the great ruling sentiments which
have their vital Source in this idea
patriotism loyalty self-devotion for the
sake of others nay what we consider the
Supreme of Earthly blessings largest
scope for individual life endowments
Powers genius character
these were the prize for which we
wrestled in that terrible Arena
more than this
involved here too
were the widest human interests
we fought for the worth of manhood for
Law and Liberty
which mean freedom for every man to make
the most of himself with Good Will of
all others without oppression or
depression
we had a deep inward vision of this at
the time though unspoken and perhaps
unclear
but no man even now can realize in
thought or recognize in fact all the
reach of good coming forth out of that
struggle and that victory for the
country
and for mankind
and that right there is a quote
from a speech by Colonel Joshua
Chamberlain
and he was at a banquet to honor the
16th main Infantry
and the fifth main light artillery
battery it was the 16th Main
who on July 1st 1863 they were ordered
to hold a position at Chambersburg Pike
but this element of men was eventually
overrun
and as they were being overrun
they took down their flag their
regimental flag
and they ripped it
to shreds so that it wouldn't be
captured
by the Confederates
and of their sacrifice of their 275 men
11 were killed 62 were wounded 159 were
taken prisoner
but because they did that because they
held the line as long as they did it
allowed 16 000 other Union troops to
retreat and regroup around Gettysburg
and of course it was the next day July
2nd
when the 20th Maine
under the charge of Joshua Chamberlain
was able to hold the Union's Left Flank
on little round top with a Bayonet
charge that stopped the Confederates the
confederate army's best chance for
victory in that battle and
essentially at that point turned the or
at least started to turn the tide of the
war
and it's no surprise
in my humble opinion that these soldiers
from Maine accounted themselves so well
they're from a state that has horse
winners
rugged terrain and a culture of hard
work and self-reliance
and today we have someone with us that
has become a Mainer
after retiring from the SEAL Teams and
is now looking to serve his country and
his State again
his name is Ed thielander and he's here
with us tonight to share some of his
experiences and Lessons Learned Ed
thanks for joining us man hey uh thank
you very much for having me on uh this
is awesome it was awesome to get out
here you know I went out to Coronado
last night uh
and watch some you know some tadpoles
playing on the on the oak course
and it hasn't changed much you know uh
it's uh that's one thing I missed from
you know jumping over to the east coast
was seeing these young frog you know men
wannabes uh just get after it and and
try and figure out you know how to
negotiate the obstacles on their own
time after training and uh yeah and yeah
watching them run back and forth to Chow
you know you run six miles a day just to
go eat in Boots
um that's not counted work out that's
just to go eat and watching that was
pretty cool
um so yeah it's great to be back out on
the west coast check it out for a little
while and I'll be popping back over to
the east coast tonight yeah the old
course is all fenced off now yeah I
can't just walk out there and do it yeah
I mean back in the day a civilian could
basically walk out there and just run
the Oak horse and now it's all fenced
off uh which is a bummer because you
know it's kind of cool that you could
just roll out there and run that thing
yeah that's a pretty brutal of course
um
and we'll get into that before we get
there before we talk about your buds
your team's experience and all that
let's start at the beginning let's start
where you came from where you grew up
what was going on you're from uh
originally from Michigan yep Romeo
Michigan so so what was going on growing
up
so yeah uh born in Marquette my dad uh
it was going to school up there uh you
know my dad did six years in the Navy
and then what do you do in the Navy he
was uh a missile Tech uh you know Subs
he wanted he was trying to talk me into
being a nuke
that's a hard conversation
he's telling me yeah you get steak and
lobster you know you don't even have to
get up to get a drink you know because
people
yeah that's because you can't get up to
get a drink and it's so crowded yeah and
then you run out of fresh milk on you
know with the fifth day and uh you know
they never turn the lights off or uh in
the hallways you know it's it's uh or
I'm sorry in birthing
and birthing they never turn them on
except once a week to clean and and then
they go in there and pull up all the
deck plates and get food out did you
ever do sub-ops when you when you were
in yeah yeah well I was at STV oh gosh I
mean which is just funny yeah you know
Team guys with nothing to do because
we're kind of all ready for whatever
we're gonna go do and we've got nothing
to do except make jokes and uh cause
trouble yeah you know we were on the
Dallas and uh
we're the first ones you know getting
ready to eat because we're ready to go
do our little gig and uh there's this
little S turn and
so we all line up and there's this pipe
that sits right about head height right
about here uh and we all lined up so you
had to hit it
um but all the the sub guys no they just
you know shifted their head around it it
was every diver and team guy that
whacked right into that thing
yeah that submarine life is is a
different kind of Life yeah respect to
the guys that do it I mean it's
I could I I would I think the longest I
was ever on a submarine before was like
maybe
a week and a half or something like that
we were on we went on to go do some to
go get inserted somewhere and bad
weather came and it wouldn't launch us
so we were just stuck there right that
was my first experience with hot racking
right you know you know what that is
Echo no hot racking it means when you
share a bed with someone
so like you're you're working one shift
when you get done I when you go to work
I get in your bed so we share a bed yeah
yeah take turns yeah take turns yeah
yeah it's yeah you can have two to three
guys yeah not cool so so when you get on
with the sdv you know the sdb is a
little wet submarine for folks that
don't know they put this basically this
garage on the back of a submarine and it
is it's wildly awesome uh because you
that whole thing is dedicated from
moving you know uh uh two or six guys
from point A to point B this big giant
garage door opens up the sdv goes out
you know 10 12 20 hours later that thing
comes back
um it's pretty wild but
we bring a bunch of folks on there to
help us out and get everything ready so
they clear out a rack of torpedoes
and uh that becomes your bear or your
beds you know it's just so I gave up my
bed to one of my guys uh because I was
getting off and he was going to stay on
and work the comms problem and I'm you
know decent sized guy I can't turn in
under that torpedo rack because the next
torpedo above you and I actually have to
squish my shoulders in tight and uh and
they in the
uh torpedo uh area they do not turn the
lights off yeah ever that thing's just
always on uh everywhere else they kind
of cycle daylight
um in the work other working areas
except the torpedo area so you're just
in there you know they do put up a
curtain it means nothing you're shoulder
shoulder head to head with you know
whatever it is 20 other dudes
and your dad's trying to convince you
that this is the way to go yeah go via
yep so was he a Submariner yeah yeah he
did uh
no he was a torpedo man he was trying to
talk me into being a nuke and uh those
nuke guys they work hard man it is no
joke that job is a tough grueling in the
freaking nuclear engine room or whatever
I don't know what you call it the
reactor room right God so to work out on
a submarine
you got to put your dosometer on because
you've got to walk past the nuclear
reactor and then they've got it's
they're all quiet workouts they did have
a square block of uh dumbbells you know
uh which is you know they all wear
tennis shoes so you don't make noise you
know so you don't get no no can hear you
from above and then it's you know it's
an elliptical not a treadmill
um so you know I don't want the pound in
other feet it's yeah you can do pull-ups
on something and you got those dumbbells
in a lip
yeah it is Jack an ideal life for a guy
that has a more of a propensity to be a
seal right right all right so your dad
so what'd your dad do after he got out
of the Navy so uh yeah he went uh went
to college up in northern Michigan
Michigan Tech in so driven in three
years working two jobs he got his
bachelor's in his master's
uh and uh you know with with three boys
and then moving down to uh Southern
Michigan Teacher Electronics teacher so
it was in high school college high
school Electronics teacher yeah and it
was legit uh I we were
he would do all this after school work
and weekend work with his kids you know
his students and we'd be in there
climbing in and around all the
electronic gear and he'd have us making
circuit boards it what I remember to be
a ridiculously young age a good a
ridiculous you know uh uh I mean like
five years old burning circuit boards
um you know we made stuff flashing
lights whatever
um but it was all fun and games and then
all of a sudden we can do some wild
stuff you know we were always forced to
figure things out I took electricity in
high school with the teacher I don't I
didn't we all haven't called him Scotty
but that's where I learned how to like
wire houses you know yeah and to this
day like I mean at one of my houses I
this is when I was still in the teams
like took a weekend redid put in an
electrical sub panel redid All the
wiring in my kitchen because it's all
jacked up and like such a great skill to
have oh yeah and it's yeah it's all
stuck with me you know I figure stuff
out we never had a new TV ever we fixed
all those old tube TVs you know and
change the channel with the pliers you
know
yeah we fixed our cars you know from
fixing our bicycles When We Were Young
Young and then we got motorcycles you
know a little you know YZ 60s uh and we
tore those down to nothing and put them
all back together again first truck you
know that was given to me to use uh you
start that thing up in a cloud of smoke
and then we tore the whole thing down uh
you know in high school on the weekends
because they had a lift and all that
stuff so did you go to school where your
dad taught no no
um he he was like like the the big high
school north or south of us you know 2
000 plus kids we were like the
the
smallest of the big schools you know so
so 32 Mile center of town was paved 33
Mile Road was dirt so we lived closer to
the dirt road
[Music]
it's what when when you were in school
are you into school are you getting good
grades getting decent grades you know uh
into the sports you know uh football
wrestling and then track kind of dropped
track off at the end and just kind of
straight it on football and wrestling uh
you know like school but not crazy into
it you know like the math
um you know decent grades that was a
Bish student you know uh nothing not
definitely not way into it were you
thinking you were going to go to college
or what was your dad steering you
towards or your mom's staring you
towards so I was getting steered towards
the Navy College Navy College Navy
College you know uh my dad really you
know went up to Ferris State University
division two school it was a college
first year I was there I became a
university whatever that job right
that's where that so you did end up
going to college one year college yep uh
and you said you got a scholarship no oh
no no no no
um no I just uh my dad went up there to
introduced me get me on the wrestling
team wanted me to you know do that you
know uh good team so you're a good
wrestler decent you know you're in high
school state wrestling did not make it
Estates messed up my knee in uh ended up
having surgery on it uh yeah I just had
like two-thirds of meniscus taken out
when you're like 17 yeah yeah so so I
had that surgery
and in two weeks I went to wrestling
camp
[Laughter]
so was that your sheep reader yeah that
was my senior year and then you healed
up enough that you could go up and you
walked onto this wrestling team at
Ferris State University yep and I was a
red shirt you know I did not compete but
I stuck it all the way out I mean I
started we started out with like 90 kids
and then there was like 17 left you know
at the end but I I was a good weight for
my coach what weight were you uh 163 165
whatever it was in college
so you're just scrapping with the yeah
our coach was was you know number one in
the nation you know when I came out here
to San Diego his big rival
um Butler was you know they were number
one number two I mean my coach in
college was number two Butler was number
one uh and uh it was cool because I was
working out under Butler at the time I
would go work out at uh uh San Diego
Community College and wrestle there you
know where Dean actually ended up going
we had the same coach a couple years
difference
that's wild yeah yeah uh so you say you
only went to you only went to college
for a year yeah uh halfway through and I
was on a uh Plastics engineering program
that there wasn't room for everybody to
do all all the plastic classes so I was
on a waiting list so I was taking my
English my math I took a 300 level
Metallurgy class as a freshman and uh I
got out of there halfway through the
year I said yeah I'm gonna go do the
option you know finish this year out
strong and then I'm gonna go be a seal
how did you hear about the teams did
your dad tell you about them no uh Adam
I guess you say Adam Blake dude um in
high school he was reading men with
green faces like the only book about
SEAL Teams at the time and I go hey
what's that about
he goes oh that's a SEAL Teams you know
blah blah blah oh that's cool he was
trying to talk me into joining the
Marine Corps with him I wish he
eventually ended up doing
um but I said hey how come you don't
want to go do that oh that's crazy you
know that's so hard it's not really
possible
check
and then so that put it in my head
that's what I want to do and I'll go and
do the college and then you know can't
quit anything never allowed to quit
anything as a child you know so I
finished the year out strong and I
signed up uh for the late entry I worked
out a little bit in the summer did a
couple uh triathlons you know because I
didn't know anything about what I was
really getting there were no books about
it there was nothing really no prep
courses what the recruiters say to you
uh come on in yep sounds great looks
like you're gonna make a great seat
great you know he tells everybody else
right right uh yeah so you know took the
ASVAB and all that happy stuff and you
know smoked that qualified to be a new
qualified to do whatever
um and uh was your dad like CSUN yeah
nuke yeah you're still trying you know
what'd your dad say once you told me
you're gonna try and go on the teams uh
yeah cool but at the same time hey you
you really want to look at you know
being a nuke yeah
uh you know being on Subs is cool you
know the whole steak Lobster thing and
you know you don't have to get up get a
drink and you know they're all a bunch
of good dudes but uh yeah I don't belong
in a submarine
I get on the sub to get off the sub to
go do something and then so did they
have die Fair will you die first die
Fair that's what I was too no so yeah
you get a guarantee to
take a try out yeah in boot camp uh and
then whether you pass that test or not
uh you are in the Navy for six years
yeah it's a great recruiting too it is a
great recruiting tool and it's the the
SEAL Teams is a great recruiting team oh
yeah because it if you know they say
that the the attrition rate is like 80
people quit or whatever something like
that right but if you start taking all
the people that came in the Navy to try
and go to the SEAL Teams I mean there's
most people don't even make it you know
two butts or at least a bunch of people
don't make it two rights so they're get
the Navy's getting a lot of a lot of
people well just you know Blue Angels I
mean that's on all the commercials
that's true too yeah we used to do seven
of them or something like that
you know and it's cool to be on the Blue
Angels changing tires uh but but uh
that's not what they're advertising
all right so you join the Navy you have
no house boot camp you're no Factor
you're a wrestler yeah boot camp was
just something to go through it was
pretty wild you go to Orlando or Chicago
yeah oh that's where all the die fair is
when it's time okay that's where I went
to so I guess it makes sense it's wild
seeing all these folks come from you
know that that boot camp was a factor
like a wow factor either the teamwork
part of it you know uh people getting
Authority as a recruit that like yeah
you never have to should ever have
authority and then and and see people
stressed out uh about the you know
simplest of things
um and that was wild to see those
differences in people that that uh
wow you know so yeah boot camp off the
books you know the boot camp Navy boot
camp is different is a lot about
isolation and staying on a ship you're
only allowed off the ship one time you
know for like the recruit weekend or
something like that uh right you have
you know
that's what the Navy's about you're
still got a boat and the Navy's about
like blue collar industrial work that's
what most of the Navy is sure and that's
why Navy boot camp is a lot about
attention to detail sure you know
following directions to a t you know
checking what you're checking your work
because you know if you're working on an
aircraft or you're working on a engine
or you're working on a parachute like
all these jobs their industrial jobs
yeah and you got to be squared away at
that thing you know as opposed to the
Army or the Marine Corps a lot of those
are field jobs you got to be doing
something in the field I mean of course
the Marine Corps has aircraft mechanics
and everything else too and so does the
Army but that the Navy is vast majority
of it is industrial work people that
know how to work on engines people that
know how to work on electronic equipment
that's what it is right so that's where
the Navy boot camps geared to I think
it's it's come a long way now if you go
watch like a Navy boot camp video they
have a simulator
in Chicago like a ship simulator that
fills with water they gotta fight fires
and so I think they did do a good job it
looks like they've done a good job at
making it more
a little bit more combat related or at
least like Navy War fighting to at least
get you that mentality because you
should have that mentality if you're in
the Navy so I think they've done a good
job moving in that direction but
essentially it's a bunch of industrial
work that you're learning how to do yeah
you know
thick thin thin thick yeah yeah the way
you fold the T-shirt this is the echo
Charles so when you fold a t-shirt for
Navy boot camp standards there's like a
certain way to fold it and it ends up
looking like there's a thin layer
a thick layer then there's a thin layer
a thin layer and then another thick
layer in there you got to learn this and
you do it like following orders
attention to deep attention to detail
before you get to play with a nuclear
reactor we want to make sure you can
fold a t-shirt wait what's thick and
what's thin it's the folds yeah you know
there's other material under there so
the first fold is thick the next two
folds are thin and then there's another
thick one it's just the way it is it's
just a it's it's this funny thing that's
you know I mean that was 1980 yeah I
don't know if they still have it but I
know Leif Babin still folds his shirts
like in a Navy manner is that right yeah
I was like a Naval Academy what the hell
is that I saw this stuff folded I was
like damn what's going on over here yeah
I'm stuck it it is a little attention to
detail things but you know some of these
folks couldn't there was a brilliant you
know young man kid uh and he wigged out
in the end he started crying oh yeah you
definitely see some people wig out I
mean there's no doubt about that wow no
doubt about that I mean I understand
some other things you know what I like I
wouldn't have wigged out for that but I
get it you know serious school and you
know I didn't see anybody wig out in the
teams but I saw him serious wig out in
serious school but uh not Navy boot camp
they yell at you yeah that's an
expectation uh should be
you know but but uh some people just
aren't used to that in their life you
know and uh wow yeah I think also people
get the impression that this is what the
whole Navy is going to be like for the
rest of my career people are gonna be
yelling and screaming and right and you
think yeah I can't take this and leave
or you know I just want to make sure you
can stand up to a little bit of stress
because eventually something might get
stressful yeah for sure uh so you get
done so do you go straight to buds after
that would you go to a school yeah core
minis so remember Maps right your
military and processing
yeah put a fifth Choice down because I
put I I I only wanted to be a seal you
know our source ratings you had to pick
a source rating because you've washed
out you would go to the Navy and do that
uh so I put down you know three choices
in an alternate well I still didn't pick
Corman yet so I said why don't you put
down a fifth alternate
and so I got the fifth alternate core
school but it was an easy the Navy yeah
last easy class it was only eight weeks
uh next class shifted like 14 weeks and
uh you know trudged through that and uh
off to what should have been buds but
they missed minorities my orders up and
sent me to Balboa
you know because they were like we're
not a my class 163 didn't start till
whatever it was April whatever so they
weren't going to get me there until like
a week before
you know but you still had pre-training
and they didn't care they needed
somebody to go work you know somebody at
the hospital was saying hey we need some
bodies so they sent me there and you
know I was working for really good
Senior Chief and I said hey you know uh
this is what I got going on I don't
think it's quite right you know I'm just
a new kid in the Navy and I'm still like
hey this isn't right um can we check it
out and so I what I would do is I would
go run down to RTC from Balboa and I
found you know uh seeing sheep Billy
Hill and goward and I said hey uh you
know I'm a senior Chiefs can I get a
little help here because I don't think
this is right I think yeah that's not
right go get your swim in we'll fix it
and so they fixed my orders but it took
a couple weeks so then I I got to buds
in a week and a half later I classed up
and started damn and you're in class 163
yeah and you classed up a week and a
half after you got there yeah you said
that's uh that's a little bit of a quick
start yeah because I didn't know
anything you know I'm seeing everybody
there they like got their you know that
rope around their belt you know and say
hey what's that about oh yeah we're
doing underwater not time tomorrow
Jack yeah uh uh were you a good swimmer
I was a decent swimmer you know um you
know I sink like a rock I basically you
know beat the water into submission
everybody has ever been tried to be a
real swimmer you cannot beat the water
into submission and go faster you know
[Music]
through the water plane yeah
I sink like a stone but you were
comfortable like not time when it did
come back as a kid you know but no not
tying
okay how do you tie that you know those
series of knots you know I didn't know
and that you know that's what we're
doing tomorrow okay how do you tie those
knots how was hell week for you in your
class
uh yeah uh you know summer hell weeks
you know just
they're warmer
um you know uh these these other guys
that are thinner or they are gonna
suffer before I was because I was I'm
you know the mesomorph you know a
naturally heavier guy
um so basically they
kept that boat on your head longer and
you know my neck will tell you about
that today still
yeah uh yeah you know
um remembering all the wild things about
about hell week you know you know what
was your worst you know thing in hell
week Tuesday
[Laughter]
so uh how do I say
uh Ryan zinke what was uh um our first
phase officer
in it at uh Chow times eat four times a
day a chow time uh he would go around
and make sure no one fell asleep and if
you nodded off
you're gonna get a jalapeno you know so
Ed being from Michigan and you know
roast beef and mashed potatoes you know
peppers like the ultimate spice and you
sparingly my mom's you know French
Canadian it's a lot more bland food I've
never had a jalapeno in my life and your
lips are blistered you know uh so it
eats the jalapeno check
and I threw up
you know it's a one mile run with a boat
on your head I threw up for a mile and a
little bit because we ran all the way to
the Oak course and we did the O course
with our boat and I threw up all the way
through that of course hauling the boat
around and then I've got no fuel in the
tank uh that was a long long day yeah I
remember that you know and then remember
the other things about you know hallucin
is a you know hallucinating you know you
know Lion's lope you know the uh you
know getting mad at my paddle I remember
it though
you know you know making us go I'm
crying hard you know that this paddle
should make me go faster you know uh
yeah remembering paddle prayers you know
uh what's battle prayers so they would
put us together around in a circle oh
it's weird paddle above the other guy's
head you got your paddle you got your
paddle so you're like this and when you
fall asleep it hits you you try and
catch self and you whack the tune it's
like is that in the program
yeah uh you know I was a really
motivated young you know a number one
bottom line man you know the guy the guy
that jumps out on the Rock Portage and
neighbors the boat and I wanted to be
that guy you know that's the spot man
that's the spot get in there let's do
this and uh when that boat's upside down
on your head uh that's the spot too
because you're taking some serious
weight yeah that's a dangerous evolution
in big waves man you know we didn't have
helmets Yeah you know we had k-pops in a
big giant you know horribly
uncomfortable life jackets uh and uh
wow now they got helmets you know dude I
I noticed they took the Stump Jump
completely out now yeah but they reduced
the stumps first and now the stumps are
all gone and they're tired tires yeah
and that's kind of because that's a
mental thing you know
um everybody knew the right stump to
jump on it's just that
all the fear of falling yeah and I don't
remember anybody falling I you know I
don't know that somebody fell and they
hit their head with the yeah Echo this
is on on the obstacle course one of the
first I guess it was this actually the
second obstacle you go across that dip
bar thing right right and then you'd hop
off and there'd be
telephone poles caught off at various
Heights in the ground like stumps and
you would have to jump from stump to
stump to stump and they'd kind of
increase in Heights and the last one was
a little was depending on which route if
you took the right route which everybody
knew right the last one was the tallest
one had to jump a little bit further for
it and then you could jump you jump up
onto this uh grab this wall this low
wall which was probably like 10 10 feet
tall or something like that from the
stump from the stump but it did take
it did take like uh what's commitment
right commitment to jump from stump to
stump yeah and it got you used to
committing right and now it's Just Tires
like you see on a football field you
know you run the tires oh okay yeah
you're right about that psychological
part right right there's a fear of
falling it's just like you know if you
focus on the the stump that you might
fall on you're not looking at the stump
that you want yeah you know like if
you're of your skiers yeah you know um
if you ski with a helmet on uh and then
you take your helmet off
there you see you ski slower especially
if you ski in the trees I mean if you're
skiing in the trees and
if you're looking for the gaps you're
good to go if you're looking for the
trees that you don't want to hit you're
going to find that tree yeah you know
and the same kind of thing it's it's
it's a it's a psychological thing you
know to get you moving forward yep and
they got helmets now too that they wear
all the time which is weird too because
like even during hell week they wear
helmets
really which is to me the agony of that
boat grinding on your head was like a
huge part of of what oh yeah yeah
because you're getting you know your
head you're getting some serious sunburn
you don't have a whole bunch of hair
yeah uh it's yeah your head's getting
blistered it's a psychological part of
it man that that uh
yeah I don't know if I'd want to wear a
helmet or not actually yeah a little
warm you know I don't know any other so
once you got done with hell week you're
in the rest of buds was there any other
major challenges for you there
um eating dry out at the island where'd
you say eat and dry yeah so you know at
at least one meal a day you had to
either do the pull-ups the Frog hill run
or the Rope climb where did you suck at
something pull-ups okay I could not yeah
gravity you know rope climb's fine
because you use your legs technique
um but man I ate wet a lot full of day
uh it was funny because for whatever
reason I never did pull-ups growing up
and uh yeah that was uh no the island
was second phase for me yeah uh that
eventually yeah or back to it I guess so
yeah eventually I mean I became a
pull-up freak you know as a big guy you
know I think uh even after my shoulder
surgeries I did you know 26 something
pull-ups like six months later it's like
it's personal challenge uh but uh yeah
so so pull-ups what was one you know
running not a great Runner you know
swimming but you know you're swimming
you know uh
yeah
not a top performer by any means uh but
just kept going forward you know and uh
you know just all you had to do was
perform you know
um pass you know but perform you know
not tying
um
normally no Factor
we did it in the dive Tower
how deep
well the ropes stay the same depth uh 10
feet zinke took me down to 50 feet
and we just hung out there and looked at
each other
and uh until he was you know tired and
then we came up to the top and there is
a set
you know it's all set what you're
supposed to be doing uh and uh
I was like okay yeah you're ready to go
yeah ready to go yeah you know
and we went down and uh then we came
back up you know and Bam next knot
dang back down again and back up and
down no so I failed that
yeah uh you know that's one thing that's
interesting what I remember about some
of the breath holding stuff like 50
meter underwater swim you're going to
buds you're like that's no big deal I
could do that
but and not tying oh it's like what's
nine feet go down there tie knot but
you're in in buds because of everything
that's going on you're constantly like
beat down so you almost always have a
cough you kind of have a cold you kind
of have like mucus you're always like
that you're always tired like like a
Four Mile time run
first phase was 32 minutes Four Mile
time run you look at that in paper on
the outside you're like what's that
that's a freaking you know I could do
that no problem then you get in there
you have boots on you got pants on
you're running in the soft sand and the
run is not four miles it's like 4.2
miles 4.4 miles 4.5 miles right and then
and and what'd you do the night before
the night before that morning four
o'clock in the morning Four Mile time
run you did you know a thousand eight
count bodybuilders so you did Buddy
carries up right down the burn so
everything is harder than it than you
think it's gonna be in buds it's not
what's on paper it's what what actually
happens is harder yeah no and you didn't
get to eat but you had to run to ciao
and you had to go through the line and
touch the hamburger that you want to eat
but there was no time to actually eat it
you know you wasted time running all
over but you that's what you must go
there to do that but there's no time to
actually sit down and eat and then you
run and you go do the other solution
because you have to be at the evolution
on time
did you get rolled for anything no no
first time every time yeah it's uh um
well I mean I failed that but but my
lungs were messed up from uh from hell
week not dying right after Halloween
that's the kind of thing that makes it
hard he's like you get done with hell
week you're jacked up man right and now
you got to go do these knots underwater
and you're like you can barely knowledge
your breath for 10 seconds so it sucks
and then you get taken down to the
bottom yeah you know and 50 feet going
down to 50 feet is no joke I mean that's
a that's a legit that's a legit swim
right uh subsurface swim that takes a
that takes a decent amount of time just
to get down to 50 right feet right and
now you got to do your little happy time
in the tower yeah the towers we went to
the bottom and sat
do you see it's gone now the tower yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh I drove
around there just checking everything
out and so what are you are you like a
semen Apprentice at this point or just
the E3 yeah yeah you're just there happy
to be there check yeah I mean your
knowledge of the Navy knowledge of what
I'm you know other than I'm signing up
I'm you know I'm gonna get to shoot blow
things up Skydive scuba dive serve my
country hell yeah you know uh let's rock
and roll that's right hey cool uh it uh
you know they learn like um
pool comp you know that was another one
where you know and I had uh
one of the main instructors uh
and was he a senior Chief at the time
yes he was I know exactly what you're
talking about
yeah and uh uh uh hey great respect you
know
um
but he ripped my mask off at the
beginning you know so basically you got
your your you got these old scuba tanks
on with uh flexible hoses that you can
tie knots into not Modern Gear either
actually soft Hollow uh hoses so you can
tie knots into them cut the air off uh
and uh you know he takes my mask off and
but leaves it on my head and I said okay
I'm not going to put it back on I'm just
going to keep he's just swim back and
forth and you get to the end you turn
around and while they're doing that
they're just coming in on you and
wrecking your gear and you have to do
everything procedurally correct and uh I
did everything procedurally correct but
since my mask was accessible I should
have put it on fail
there you go
so I had to do that again uh and I got
even harder instructor uh would
considered harder but fair in my mind
you know uh a super dude but he uh
um yeah I got put through the ringer
again but but you know I put my mask on
when it was available and uh lesson
learned lesson learned yeah a whole
bunch of learning because I didn't do
any of the you know well they didn't
teach you that pretty hand because that
was third phase for me you know I've
been there you know you know back into
shape again uh it takes like a year this
is what they say to recover from hell
week you look at some of those cats
um and I remember you know I was a class
corpsman you know sending dudes to the
hospital with Encephalitis you know
their hands are just you know big giant
puff balls and their feet you know uh
it's uh and we didn't get any sleep in
hell week you're supposed they're
scheduled to sleep you know uh but we
did not get that yeah I think the
scheduled sleep might be a couple hours
total something like that yeah there's
two blocks of it and you're supposed to
get dry first
um that one I know my class got because
they you know they tell you some story
like hey the the the the the skipper
said we're being too hard on you guys
we're we have to stand down for eight
hours you guys go get dry and you guys
can go to bed and we'll wake you up
tomorrow
and I mean you know it's right
right still you put on dry clothes and
then you go and you actually get in your
bed
and this is probably probably Tuesday
yeah and and then you know a half an
hour later they come in and they get you
up and hit the surfing right but but
guys quit because it's it's a smart move
to get people to quit oh yeah because
they go into the comfort zone right and
then they bring him back out you know
you gotta watch out for that comfort
zone bro that thing will grab a hold of
you oh yeah that's like when you're
doing a long ruck march yeah yeah if you
stop you got to stop for like
five minutes eight minutes ten minutes
at the most then you gotta get your ass
up and start walking again because you
start going into that 15 minute break 20
minute break your body gets cold and
you're screwed getting back up but uh
yeah so I we slept that point and you
know you fall sometimes you're just
falling asleep I mean there's nothing
you can do about it you're gonna fall
asleep yeah the uh so they got us into
dry clothes
and we had a kid in our class that
um quit on Tuesday you know whatever 20
clap whatever you know years before came
back and uh so he had knowledge up to
Tuesday
uh and so we cut you know he knew
something about it so we got dried but
then they put us on the grinder and uh
on the pavement where we worked out and
you know we started doing flutter kicks
and uh
um instructors up there doing our
flutter kicks he brought the class
leader up there and uh headed the class
leader started leading us and then the
instructors walked away
and we're on our backs we're in dry
clothes that's the standard
um class leader would not let us go to
sleep it's like
yeah you know he's trying going around
making us say our social security
numbers or birthdays you know trying to
keep everybody awake and just like I I
go and I'm I am a kid you know you're
doing the job for them
[Laughter]
and uh uh
so then they at the end because they're
you know in that first phase corner
office
just giggling I I imagine yeah you know
uh and then they uh let us you know said
all right they're like trying to figure
out how to make that officer quit yeah
it's too dumb they weren't gonna make
that guy quit that guy's a horse
he doing the underwater swim you gotta
swim you gotta swim tied up
um and you got to do a flip into the
water and then you swim 25 meters flip
and then turn around and come back
without a mask on
um so he did it flutter kicking
damn yeah no no no this is not not the
tied up one the one you just the right
underwater the 100 meter
um tied up one you know uh but but you
have a mask on I think on that one uh
but the other one you didn't have a mask
he's flutter kicking it and he swam off
course
finally got back on course made it there
and back it
hard hardest Stone yeah a college
football player you know uh but yeah so
they put us put us to bed and
um
somebody had to watch it and you're not
allowed to have a watch you have no
concept of time or day or anything uh
and uh you're always trying to figure
out what day it is a little bit you know
uh you know trying to remember what meal
you count from meal to meal basically
um and uh yeah so 22 minutes that's what
we got for hell week
sleep it's not a lot of sleep no legit
so you graduate from Buds and what did
you want to go where did you end up
going teams you went to team three right
yeah I went to team three so you get the
dream sheet and you know I put like all
I I wanted to go to Maine because I I
love the snow and it was like started
goes yeah no you can't do that that's
stupid because you can't you got to go
to a team first you know that we have
four billets up there in Maine that's
how I eventually got up there uh but I
put team I want to do cold weather I
want to put team two
um you know I I put Team Four I don't
remember what else I put but you put all
the East Coast teams I think so and the
Navy said West Coast
and uh you know I had a great time there
uh you know um
the first platoon you know um Mark Mark
Crampton Bob Edwards you know um folks
that you remember you know uh Miss Mark
yeah Mark was freaking awesome man yeah
dude uh crazy you know we can talk about
that just the whole we got to watch out
Mark you know say it yeah committed
suicide and uh completely unexpected
totally you know I mean that dude was
solid as Stone yeah it's just awesome
mentor to so many people I mean Mentor
but uh wow uh a smile on his face lit
every single time I interacted with him
which was sometimes on a daily basis but
I mean for his whole career he just
always had a good attitude about
everything right about everything that
was going on
and yeah so it's totally unexpected you
know he retired he's been retired he had
been retired for quite a few years maybe
what do you think five years seven years
something like that something like that
yeah I mean he kept on just moving on up
and doing good things for the teams and
everybody around him I mean always
self-motivated self-improvement guy
always looking for that next thing to
make him and everybody around him yeah
and helping and not not just the teams
but he would like help kids that were
wrestling had like a wrestling club he's
just doing everything right yeah you
know but yeah that was that was a uh
that was a great platoon
um you know uh Westpac you know did uh
so where did you deploy to the pi or did
you go where'd you go Pi
um Pi
um Pano tubo hit okay you know just
after we left and we came back uh I came
back with foxtrot platoon
um and uh you know the ashes everywhere
yeah so you weren't in the pi one
pentatubo hit no no it was not you came
how was a workup and everything your
first platoon being a new guy oh yeah I
was in Corman taking the hits you know
uh
we had a good bunch of new guys uh uh um
you know uh yeah Gino Bam Bam uh
freaking ghost man Dave Casper lost him
to cancer uh recently uh I don't know if
you remember these guys were still
around there at the time
um yeah uh just a good yeah uh but legit
you know we
you make a mistake because as a new guy
back then you know you're gonna pay for
it I really didn't get too much grief I
mean one day out at an island you know
with the olden Island you know with the
tree of Woe and yeah uh they were they
were you know uh tuning some folks up I
was on watch you know I was not
touchable
Dave the ghost man Casper they were
going after him and they chased him he
got up on top of the millivans and the
rsus that were over by the fence and
that's there's a gap big enough to drive
a semi-tractor trailer and unload it
he jumped over that barbed wire and made
it out into the desert and spent the
night out freedom freedom
right on and then so what did you do on
deployment back then uh you know I I was
training you know a Fed uh you know to
go to any cool countries
yeah uh I had a blast in you know South
Korea um you know we went to Japan did
some sub-ops there we did uh uh shoot
where else would we go
um I mean there wasn't a whole bunch of
traveling you know the
um golf kicked off we deployed early
you know I did not we didn't do did you
backfill someone that went to the gulf
or something yeah uh CLT five worst job
ever in the teams hey we just need you
to backfill for the guys that are going
to war you're like so yeah I missed out
uh you know significant parts of the
workout you know as a new guy too and
you know it is a corpsman
yeah
back then we didn't have the training
that they got now yeah you know and I
could have got some more of that you
know uh but I mean the first stitches I
ever
did other than on a uh uh you know a a
fruit
was my own knee or work about an island
and they had uh uh a pistol course we
were running there was a pipe you had to
crawl through that had bullet holes in
it and you know you know dug on my knee
and you know I
I never even
used lidocaine because I was not taught
that in core School
you know and I hadn't been through uh um
the EMT course where you got all that
yeah at this point in the workup and so
a whole platoon watching me because I'm
the doc in the platoon and uh which
again was just crazy wrong you know from
what they get a platoon guy now had more
training a regular platoon guy yeah than
what I had there they're so squared away
and uh you know I never tied a knot on a
human you know a stitch and so
everybody's watching it and uh you know
figured it out yeah
uh doc uh yeah doc irk was you know
supervising me and uh I figured it out
you know uh
cleaned it cleaned it out myself uh and
that was you know but um
they were you know we came back second
we were like getting ready to get uh
horizontal Keynotes out you know 92 time
frame 91 92 and that was
that was a fun little uh you know
jump into the deployment we jumped into
doing that and you you've done the quick
Ducks where you're uh um
in recoveries where you're driving right
into the back of a 47. yeah yeah yeah we
were doing in the back of 53s well
that's wild hail rotor yeah how's that
work that's got to be sketchy especially
when you're by yourself but I you know
uh what are they like hey you got this
you drive it in there we'll wait yeah so
so so we you know everybody goes out and
uh no big deal you know but they're um
it's uh it's fully inflated just about
uh or it was a and drive take everybody
on Shore and then recover back onto the
same Hilo by yourself it's 240 knot
rotor wash from a uh a 53 yeah so Echo
just to explain what he's talking about
so a ch-53 is a big giant helicopter but
you ever seen the helicopters that have
two big rotors on top right that's what
we would normally do this on well that's
called a 47 or a 46 is a little small
but a 47 is big
but the 53 has a tail rotor like a
normal helicopter so when you drive in
the back you're coming close to this
thing for sure oh yeah no you you come
in you're coming in at a 45
um and you've got to make sure your your
engine's on tilt you're coming in at a
45 to avoid the tail rotor because it's
legit uh again that rotor wash can flip
that boat I put anything extra in it uh
into the bow of the boat and I would
lean forward and holding onto the tiller
and leaning forward into the boat you
punch through that and it's a wall when
you get through it there's Dead Space so
so you you've got a you've gotta make a
right hand turn
and gun it one more time until you're
and you're in and you're inside the
helicopter it's like uh by yourself it's
pretty wild to do
um and as a new guy I mean it's my
second platoon uh without a workup so
that was that was pretty wild and that
whole so those were Air Force spec ops
guys you know there was their big uh
um thing and it was uh yeah we did
exercises with those guys too in the
Philippines
um you know the uh
the C-130 that they had
um it got shot by
you know NPA or some farmer that didn't
like a flying and disturbing their Yak
or what whatever uh and uh so it it took
a round through and through the plane
we never knew they they landed it
patched it is their exercise and that
thing was back up in the air when it
when an Air Force bird you know breaks
um and it's in a nice place like Hawaii
you're there for a couple days we never
knew it even got hit yeah you know and
this is training again you know it's uh
um yeah that was that was
pretty wild now this didn't you fall
somehow like oh yeah what was that all
about
ouch just um so I I always went off uh
um Joshua Tree
um all right a while to go climbing on
the weekends you know uh Lou langless
you know talk we're all in a
um
Andy Rios Lou
um who else was in the barracks um you
know go off climbing on the weekends you
know we were still in the barracks and
the teams at that time
um and so you know off camping
and I was a pretty decent climber right
off the bat you know my uncle up in
Canada would take me climbing uh once in
a while as a kid and uh rarely but
um I just liked it and uh I went up
there no no one could go climbing with
me so cool I just go find somebody when
I get up there
so
I had The Soloist you know it's a
self-bullet device you tie off to the
bottom and as you progress you keep
putting Pro in it's a caming unit and I
did like a five eight and I'm funny I
remember the names of the clients
because uh Mike's books it's on the
intersection Rock right there uh in
Joshua Tree and then uh I just hung
dogged this I got to the top set up a
top rope
um making it safer uh and I just did
like a Mike's books like a five eight
and then the next one was like a 511
um which is above my what I could do I
was 10c-ish climber
um so I just kind of cheated my way up
on that literally you know because you
can you can hang on your pro hang on
your whatever yeah well you just pull on
your rope a little bit because I'm
self-bullying top rope again oh okay um
get to the top and and uh you know
there's uh uh lady that wants to go
climb with me I'm like check you know
and it's all downhill from there yeah so
I throw my rope down and uh and I go do
the down climb and I look up
and there's my rope it's caught in a
crack
all right I gotta hurry up I got the
four pieces of pro that I set that top
rope up with
and
I climb up there get to the Rope put it
back through the belay device and when
you're when you're using that soloist if
you're off track
um
it drags so I'm in this bowl and there's
a uh there's an overhang so I gotta
reach out and around
um and I was doing it and it's actually
a pretty easy climb it's like a five
seven
um but I didn't feel comfortable with it
and I had no idea what was really up
above me it was really it was dumb uh
and so I said nope not gonna do it
so I jump back into that bowl but I took
up the slack and that one piece of pro
that I set in kept my feet from planting
but it popped that Pro and I flipped out
of there backwards and I uh you know I'm
40 feet up
and I I come against the vertical face
I palmed The Rock broke my left wrist
tucked into a good plf and I landed in
this standstone wash and it folded me
like a book separated both my shoulders
chipped my ankle and whatever else that
was a train wreck and there was a class
for guides just uh 100 feet away and
they got me the rest way down I didn't
have a bar to go and uh that called you
know and the ranger said hey you know
we've had a lot of people fall from
there they either land here in the sand
because if I went if I would have pushed
off a little bit further I would have
landed in the sand probably wouldn't
have been happy either
um and he said yeah they usually live
they land over here or they land where
you do and they don't uh just by chance
they landed right in the middle of the
wash I was tucked into a tight plf
parachute Landing full
um you know just not a recent graduate
of because my this is before my first
platoon okay I was not gonna not deploy
um so I didn't want to go to 29 palms
and get stuck out there I call Gina
whoop Gino came picked me up and uh with
another team guy and uh you know I said
yeah just dropped me off a Balboa I'll
get it you know and they you know did a
couple you know basically you get into
going to Balboa on a Saturday night what
do you got in there a whole bunch of
colds a whole bunch of you know that's
what they have for an option to get
their kids taken care of and uh and go
up to the nurse so you're gonna say when
I've had to go Balboa on like a SAT
depending on what time it's like
Saturday at two o'clock in the morning
it's a drunk Sailors that are oh you've
gotten fights and beat up it's like such
a disaster no this this is this is early
uh or late evening yeah so you're all
right they haven't gotten drunk enough
to get end up in the hospital yet yeah
but but I'm there and the uh the triage
nurse you know says uh hey I'm Ed you
know I'm uh uh you know I I fell and I
hurt my you know I'm banged up whatever
I say and it was fill out this clipboard
and come back to us and my neck is
jacked up I can't turn you know and I
sit down and I start to think about
filling it out but I'm looking you know
I'm looking like this
you know I can't turn my head and go I
just stand back up and I said ma'am
um I fell 40 feet in a rock fall and my
neck hurts sir please don't move and
they strapped me into a backboard
wouldn't you know x-rayed my neck you
know what else hurts you know this is 10
hours after the fall everything hurts
um and they x-rayed me they didn't find
anything you know they didn't x-ray
everything there was more things that
hurt than my wrist and my my ankle you
know
um but uh yeah um later on I found out
so
I went climbing two weeks later with my
this is three weeks before deployment
but I had no strength in my left wrist I
didn't know why
and my little brother wanted to go
pre-deployment leave we went up to
Canada went climbing you know
um
young kids that drive but I deployed in
in I think a total of three weeks I got
acupuncture like the next day because I
could not raise my arms above my head
uh you know but I got acupuncture stick
a needle in my from an acupuncture
student in Coronado so that's good it
worked she was you know uh into it yeah
yeah stuck a needle in my hand and my
shin and uh all of a sudden I could
raise my hands above my head and you
know so we went on deployment and I had
to do we had to do a PRT
um
and I'll tell you on camera here I
cheated I did not do the pull-ups I kind
of cycled around but I did the Run
probably the slowest I ever ran three
miles at that point in my life but I was
able to pass everything and uh
um
yeah like so wrestling tournament the
fleet comes into town
and uh
um carrier group so they all kinds of
activities so they don't go out in town
and cause trouble you know and uh
so I'm wrestling in this tournament
and I I re-educated the break in my
wrist in the first match
and then in the finals I re-separated my
shoulder and uh I yeah my bowed out at
that time happily took second so I kept
re-separating my shoulders like every
three months one or left one of the
right one left one of the right one you
know uh just a young kid can move
forward and uh I was the corpsman but I
didn't really know a whole bunch you
know so yeah keep moving forward keep
going yeah so what'd you get to do when
you got done with that second platoon at
Team three
so uh so in between uh those platoons I
screen for for Dev group oh okay and uh
uh yeah they said we don't want years of
Corman getting your cross rate I said
yes because I didn't want to be a Corman
uh
I could have stayed you know with more
training and all that okay but but I
just want to be a you know architis team
guy you had to cover your own Evolutions
back then and I never did because I
always found somebody else to cover them
you had to work at it though and I said
I should not have to work to have
someone else cover my platoon Evolutions
that's just the way it used to be from
moons ago
um and so I screamed positive I uh
jumped right into uh uh uh foxtrot
platoon uh did that the end of their
work up really and then jumped right
onto the deployment and uh came back
from that and young kid you know we
never did a CQB work up I made the
mistakes I made and uh
um then they said you know so I didn't
make it through and then where do you
want to go and uh you know Seal Team
Four uh just because the reputation and
uh um I wanted to get to the East Coast
you know I said hey I think I put you
know two and four and they said they
didn't give me whatever I wanted I said
let's go going forward of South America
and uh so I went and did that
and then you so you show up at Team Four
just back into platoon life yep um hey
can you deploy in two weeks check have
your uh are you a sixth Gunner
I am now
so that's your for you're your third
platoon if you get assigned as a pig
Gunner yep uh well I mean dude as a
Corman I wanted to carry the pig the
medical gear and everything else you
know again happy new guy but so so yeah
um you know I can work the pig and so I
went out and uh bought myself some uh
you know 200 round uh pouches and uh
figured out made some Gear Up and off
the deployment I went
um and uh yeah can you be the diver yeah
it could be the diver up uh
you know I was diving since I was a kid
you know um I died I think I qualified
when I was 15 or 16. very comfortable in
the water
um
and uh yeah so so we I got Dengue Fever
bad deal also what's the deal with that
yeah
um you know uh yeah get bit by a
mosquito and uh you know I got up to
106.5 temperature bad deal uh not at
that point though so we were in Panama
and I got I didn't know what I had I was
just trashed you know
um just hot spikes
um colds I mean can't walking outside
just to go put a piece of mail in the
mailbox you know outside the barracks
and I'm freezing and it's 98 Degrees
um and then you know go back inside in
the air conditioning and I'm just all of
a sudden you know just up and down and
up and down but then I got better
so there's a trip to Colombia
can I get on there yeah throw them on
the bird
when we landed in brown Kia
um
and they literally kicked our pallet off
at the end of the runway because it was
a very hot area
um
it just hit again you know I got better
for like a couple of days and
um we go uh Tracy skinners or something
uh the town we were in
and my fever got up to 106.5 and uh you
know as the other new guy Corman I
wasn't in Corman anymore but uh it's
like you feel good and I think I'll get
better in a little bit you know but yeah
either iced in and luckily we were there
with the sbu guys and uh
um they brought an air conditioner you
know we put an air conditioner in the
building we're in we're talking one Dirt
Road Town you know that tease into the
river and uh yeah that was uh does
Dengue Fever stick with you for the rest
of your life like uh not you don't get
this um if you get it again it's
supposed to be really really bad uh but
no it's not like malaria
um but man it takes forever to recover
so on that triple month-long trip
um so this is why I don't like freaking
travel bro I'll stay right here well I
don't like leave in America my wife's
always like hey let's go to this place
I'm like no how about you want to go
somewhere Panama how about freaking
Northern California
we go to Temecula how's that sound yeah
she wants to go to some foreign Place
bro I did all that yeah and I didn't get
Dengue fever and I don't want to get it
no I mean bad deal
um from from Seal Team Four I know
somebody that's had everything yeah
is yeah so back in the day in in the 90s
well even before that the teams were
geographically oriented so team one was
southeast Asia Shield team two was
Europe Seal Team three was supposed to
be Southwest Asia Seal Team Four was
South America and tilting four you know
had had done the stuff in Panama had
lost guys in Panama had you know the the
combat experience really right of the of
the era
um so I can imagine that probably played
into your mindset of wanting to go to
Team Four and and Spanish speakers were
going to Team Four right and I mean
there were still you know um all the
snow cap Ops that they were legit doing
you know whether it was just you know
sitting on a mountain top of the radio
or getting involved with the DEA I mean
that was happening
um and this was one of those gigs where
we were going in and training these
folks and then we were going to go in as
a radio relay
um so at the end we were going in as a
radio relay simply walked in an insane
amount and
um and I'm the 60 Gunner and enough
weakest snot from from Dengue fever and
uh
um sun up to sun down we did
ridiculous so it's not it was not
through the jungle it was through the
edges of Open Fields that had all these
um
lava rocks you know softball size a
little bigger smaller
to get into Columbia at that time frame
the Marines controlled the mill group so
to get access to the country you had to
go through the Marines Marines were
trying to build the riverine assault
teams the rat teams so you had to take a
marine fighting force with you
you know an o1 you know uh staff
sergeant and uh you know a Corporal
um so we
tagged on and yeah two states that way
you had your platoon right so did you
have a squad or how many guys did you
this was a squad okay but but then we
had all the sbu guys and we were so we
were training the spu guys was training
their Folks up we were training our
folks up and uh you know we were in the
middle of 30 dudes
um you know plus on this uh hike
um and uh uh we never saw anything you
know uh we went in the dry hole and and
back out
this Marine uh lieutenant
read a book or seals
don't wear socks
and that dude's feet were has wrapped
just trash yeah bad bad deal
yeah how far of a hump was it ridiculous
um it was it was I it was like 20 clicks
we walked from Sun before Sundown we did
two hours in the daylight through the
night and then came up two hours after
and we never stopped we got there dried
hole turn around go you know the photo
was open field you know foot thing like
20K you gotta condition your feet for
that like a lot and then there's some
advantages to it because socks hold
water and if you're like working in the
jungle you can get used to it and you
can be a good thing but if you roll out
for your first time no socks but Team
guys were doing that because they
weren't walking anywhere yeah that's
that's another literally I mean swimming
up the edge of the stream or the river
you know 50 uh tops yards if not 50 feet
um doing the hit and back in the water
again there was reason for it
um that this was known to be a long walk
yeah
yeah no his feet were not serviceable
so you're you're down there how many
platoons are you do you end up doing at
Team Four
uh
three I know one of one of these
platoons you meet your wife right
uh in between actually okay we'll have
that go down yeah uh eod's uh explosive
Ordnance disposal guy married to uh uh
Spanish lady Liliana was up in Virginia
Beach uh learning English no okay and uh
yeah so so I I was trying to learn
Spanish you know I took a couple little
you know classes on it but uh
um so I you know
yeah it was perfect you know how did she
get to be come to Virginia Beach to
learn Spanish English funny she knew uh
another team guy's wife
um and was going to stay with them I
ended up staying with cheese uh
branchesio and uh and his wife and then
however uh uh the EOD guy and his wife
introduced us
yeah and she's from where Venezuela okay
yeah
so she's got an interesting viewpoint on
the way things go down from a
governmental perspective yes she does
you see what happened to her now if she
sees us coming here man she sees it
coming here and uh
um yeah we'll get into it later I'm sure
but definitely the big push to do this
thing that we're doing now yeah that's
got to be crazy um so you end up so you
end up getting married to her yep uh
yeah we got married and uh you know I
was always trying to not get married
because I liked exactly what I do
because I was always in a platoon you
know and uh
um and at this point you know
um
still happy being a platoon our first
you know first six months of marriage
was all you know I was out of platoon I
was Unemployment uh get back from that
and
at that point we still had training
um at the teams and uh and so
Team Four it used to just be rotate out
do a stint and training and then back I
mean it was as really a crazy quick
Handover Team Four you know this is just
before we started putting it to the
groups and Team Four said no you're in
training for 18 months
uh which is right I didn't have to like
it you know uh so I was in training and
Mar Ops I was like
you know and and Diving I was like not
what I want but but I made it what I
ended up doing with it is training it
into you know even though they're
we had turnover was was uh you know a
minimal turnover in platoons back then
too so we had a lot of folks could just
do things you know you could do ops
right at the beginning of platoon work
up it wasn't going to be perfect but
they'd figure it out so I took um
marops and basically we ended up doing
um some down Pilots with it uh and other
things we you know it was 85 and they
just needed somebody in there they could
you know because there was wasn't any
live fire in it uh although I did end up
putting it in there uh uh with uh Pat
the uh the guy running the the diving
portion you know we were doing some
sniper shots with uh diving our gear and
doing some pretty complicated uh
um you know we'd get the
um Coast Guard involved or the auxiliary
which really is your personal boat you
know a bunch of older older dudes that
just want to do good with their personal
boat and doing indigenous you know we
had a blast doing down to North Carolina
and doing a live fire shot you know
um in town
um you know 285s you had to bring us a
chief on board to certify the shot we
couldn't safe and all that stuff but we
were just you know yeah it's awesome it
was good you know made it uh you know
Adam Winters got involved with it he was
the the captain of the team captain at
the time and he loved it and he loved
the brief because I was always doing
these curved balls in there just not not
straight on you get to have a happy
successful training Mission you know
there's always a curveball and I
he wanted you know I briefed it that way
and we did it that way and uh he
actually had his brother who's uh I
think uh Navy pilot you know at 14 pilot
at the time I think would be the down
pilot for us one time you know he was
doing a bunch of stuff out in town
um instead of just around the base and
then you know turning rectangles and
triangles out in the ocean we actually
were doing Ops we went out to Chas light
you know over the horizon
launched off the old piece uh uh the PCS
and Over the Horizon
over the beach into Back Bay and all the
75 nautical miles and actually did a
pilot recovery in the intercoastal
waterways on a piece of property that I
was going to buy and then later on a
property that I bought I had to do
reconnaissance on it
um and uh just trying to you know
um it wasn't going to be regular old
yeah Mar Ops yeah that's what it takes
is guys that are going to take the
training and just step it up to the next
level it's always awesome and the next
folks took it even higher than that for
me that's the idea you know always
better better better uh without getting
too many crazy drift into it then you
end up you end up going to DLI right
yeah yeah uh
my shoulders are getting really bad
um you know I literally couldn't move
you know like refrigerator magnets
around anymore and uh so I went out
there and rehabbed you know that was the
idea of rehabs right there did you have
to get surgery yeah so I I I didn't yeah
they wouldn't do it um I wanted to do it
right off that deployment
and um they wouldn't do it they wanted
me to do rehab first
and I got orders DLI for the basic and
the intermediate and I went out there
with this is 97ish
something like that
um and uh
um
yeah taking her out there without fast
computers and these you know phones you
can talk to to translate for you I mean
dli's six and a half hours of Spanish a
day every day
um and four hours of homework at night
uh and uh legit I mean I can I I can
speak and uh definitely with you know my
mother-in-law living in her house at
various points in father-in-law I mean I
got it down and would your wife speak
Spanish to you all all the time when you
got home from DLI yeah I mean so she
spoke better English uh when we met that
I spoke Spanish so our natural language
together was English
um it was kind of like the go-to when my
brain got tired but but uh yeah for the
most part I could say Hey how do you say
this you know uh instead of you know
looking it up in the dictionary and
figuring out how to because you couldn't
right now you just talk to your phone
and it'll tell you so so that was that
was cool it takes you about four months
to get it to click where you can
actually go out and see you know
[Music]
um
yes Monterey and everything else out
there but man that that was a great
experience and it was just us no kids
that you know us and a dog when you're
speaking when you're speaking Spanish
now do you think in Spanish
I can yeah yeah I don't speak it as much
as it used to I am right now my
mother-in-law is living with us so it's
it's back in the game again uh because
does she speak any English she does it's
just it's never clicked with her you
know um she's older and
she's always taken the the classes I
mean genuine effort it's just not
clicking you know um but she can't as
you get along but
she wants her brain to rest you know if
you go you go to a foreign country and
you are trying to speak in their
language uh to whatever degree you can
it's tiring
um and uh I mean I've I can speak you
know to the Cabo to the Corporal and I
can speak to the you know uh Secretary
of State uh uh in Spanish in and a half
you know so it's varying degrees of
Spanish you know uh MLG
it's like the Secretary of State and
secretary uh justice uh all wrapped into
one dude and you know as a chief
um you get to talk to these folks and
you're talking about how to develop you
know ranges in Panama or wherever
um but man at the end of the day your
brain is tired because all the
colloquialisms for the different
countries
um they all come into play you say one
thing one country that that means
something else in another another
country and you can get yourself in
trouble
you know but but it's a whole different
animal once you get to speak uh
but uh so the total time at DLI was what
was the total time at bli learned in
Spanish uh 10 months yeah I graduated
the the basic class early to because the
intermediate class was was going to
overlap
and so I jumped into that and then uh
um again it's just us too and a dog and
a cat eventually uh
and uh yeah
um drove back across the country
um and uh said hey my shoulders are
trashed so we cut on uh cut on both
shoulders seven weeks apart
um as soon as I gained enough function
with uh my left hand uh you know they
did the right one or whichever one it
was
um and I've had it tuned up since I had
another one done a few years ago
um yeah it's uh it's an ongoing problem
and then obviously you go back to Team
Four after you get done with yeah I went
back to Team Four
um and uh yeah I went into uh you're a
chief now no uh no um
first class first class okay no second
class I was not not a rate Grabber I was
not a I I was happy where I was I mean
it was uh um happy with the leadership
you know and uh I'm Not always
completely happy but uh I always say it
um yeah you know you really shouldn't be
if you're happy with what's going on hey
uh and it's working you're a team
um be happy with it uh but when you
finally decide at the end that you're
not happy with it it's kind of too late
so you're an E5 and now you go back to
Team Four yeah and then jumping into
another platoon your shoulders healed
healed up enough
um
so I was in Echo platoon knowing that I
was going to get the surgery they were a
CD counter drug platoon you know doing
stuff mostly in the Caribbean and
um the mass Chief said yeah hey we broke
it we'll fix you and it was just the
with the idea hey
um you know Ed squared away he'll do the
paperwork whatever stick him in the
background I got the surgeries done you
get a month
um convalescent leave and I you know uh
I literally because I did the surgeries
without any anesthesia just just the um
the nerve block off the table and went
to the team you know to give them
whatever paperwork and check in with I
was just you know I was excited the
chief said that and I never took leave
um I just wanted to get signed up to
start my uh physical therapy at its
physical therapy
twice a day at work our Medicals right
in the middle of the compound and I'd
get a full session
and then I would get like a partial
session and then I brought my wife in
they taught her how to do all the
exercises I built the pulley at home uh
you know to pull my arm up and down and
built the fingerboard so you can climb
the wall with your fingers and uh I mean
six months you know I did the PRT and uh
legit though you know they cut so they
did it fully open they did Rock blazes
um yeah the same week same doctor and
they did his they scoped his
um but mine were pretty much kind of
collarbones were tent stakes and you
know kind of big piece of cauliflower so
you wanted to get his big hands in there
and trim them down so they remove your
deltoid
um and uh I'm awake and they have a
Makita drill
check
and they drill two holes at 90 degrees
to each other and then lasso that thing
entire deltoid back down
um so so it's because they want to get
in there and see it all
and six months later uh PRT with with uh
you know uh a very Stern Mass Chief
there that's very
strict on pull-ups
um I uh yeah 26 pull-ups 105 push-ups
the whole swim everything so you're
pretty much good to go six months later
yeah I mean I was tuned up and ready to
go uh and uh yeah into the platoon you
know I I even built uh you know before
the all the cool conics box workout
boxes I I went over to sdv and got them
to weld some stuff up weld a bench that
would collapse up and fit in one of
those uh ISU 90s you know built a
pull-up car to go across the the doors
when you open it uh and uh you should
have patented that stuff yeah buddy hey
you know Team guys are pretty Innovative
you know uh Dane a guy in my second
platoon you know he kind of invented uh
the the Camelback you know but it was
what do you use like an IV bag or
something he used uh a uh two quart
collapsible canteen and an IV uh tube
you know and had it on his back but hey
you know you can it's cool to come up
with the idea there's Innovation you
know inventatives and Innovation you got
to get it to Market yeah well there's
yeah there's execution too because you
got to be able to actually do it you
actually make it happen right I always
you know um
this sounds so obvious now but I was a
radio man right yeah and so when I'm
carrying the radio I have my little
flashlights and you know regular double
A flashlights little double A
flashlights you put a red lens over them
you tape them all up so you could be
like like a little pin like a little
pinhole of light right right right but
still you got to worry about the
batteries I mean you're do go like on a
four day Recon you your batteries are
gonna so it's a pain and I remember
looking at the pilots with their lip
lights just the little LEDs yeah
thinking wow I wonder what that thing is
and then by the time the war started
someone made those little just LED click
flashlights outside oh that's the
smartest thing ever yeah and I had two
ideas in my freaking head and they
didn't connect together to say hey man
it's real obvious here's a cool little
flashlight you could use and and make it
into like something everybody could
carry yeah you know and until
until somebody comes up with a limpet
backpack Team guys were swimming with
this bomb with magnets on their in their
hands you know I've seen the drawings of
that you know Rico
um he uh uh and I think you know who I'm
talking about you know he uh uh invented
the Limpet backpack simple idea yeah you
know a backpack that with a metal plate
in it that you stuck this Limpet
explosive mine on it and you would swing
with it on your back yeah it seems so
obvious so obvious because somebody
invented it yeah uh the chest seal the
asherman chest yes team guy yeah
made this thing that everybody carries
now right it seems kind of obvious but
you know it's everybody was happy with a
glove yeah you know
your ID cards
yeah what a brilliant thing yeah um
not everybody comes up well sometimes
you come up with a great idea so you so
you made your ISU 90 you're you're out
there you're out ready to work out of a
box yep and uh you know back with a
platoon again you know tuned up and uh
and you guys are doing counter drug what
was that deployment like
so was it just a bunch of little
deployments uh um they had the CD money
you know and then you named everything
you bought was a counter drug stapler
you know cow
you know it's a different pot of money
right and you're going down and you're
doing Recons no we're just working with
the locals uh it is it's really fit for
an internal defense really just getting
them tuned up and and huge some huge
exercises and like we would Island hop
for some of them and uh you know do you
know the Navy the Army has more
commission ships than the Navy uh which
is pretty wild our Army's a big machine
you know is it still like that I don't
know someone said it's not uh and I no
desire to confirm it or not but it's
just a wild stat they have more
helicopters in the Air Force yeah I mean
they're a monster they're they're huge
uh the big green machine so we would
Island hop
um
on their uh LSU 2000 just a big giant
landing craft and we'd get off there and
go stay in a hotel and go teach you know
and uh and then another year we went to
Belize and they had us staying in the
middle of a soccer field with countries
you know and a line of outhouses uh not
as nice uh Belize the islands you know
vacation land Inland different animal
um and uh that was wild you know there
were some countries that did not want to
be there they just wanted the gear and
they wanted there because they were told
and uh you know that was like a
hurricane disaster
um giant exercise where you know you
know terrorists take over the local
school while you know everything's going
on and and uh huge monster exercise my
first uh my first bout with killer bees
you know uh have you ever done seen that
uh uh swarmer killer bees and I think
I've
no actually no I've I've driven remember
in San Diego for a while Echo Charles
there was like bees it's like so yeah
I've driven through some swarms of bees
you know and I don't know if it was
quite the murder wasp or whatever those
things were right but no I've not dealt
with actual legit Killer Bees No
Cloud just coming across and uh um yeah
one guy just screamed get in the vehicle
or lay down flat and this Cloud came
over the entire field and then just went
away it was the craziest thing did
anyone get attacked no one got hit uh
significant that I remember it was just
the weirdest thing
um but that happened they weren't really
living up to the rest no
um we were in we were in Colombia once
and and actually doing you know
kind of something you know uh going in
you know uh and uh
the locals sat down on a hive and
underground you know ground Hive and
jumped up and ran and left all their
guns
and I don't you know it literally I mean
it was it was horrible it was a cloud
again and uh um and we're in a bad spot
actually you can't be without your gun
uh uh and uh so I've got unless you're
getting attacked by bees then you said
but it's also where these guys live yeah
you know I mean it's just uh
um yeah just outside of Cartagena uh um
we're you know they they take the the
mothership down that's you know it's a
sandbagged big giant fairy uh and they
take it down and in and go in and uh
um it's bad guy land don't drop a gun
but they did uh and so I've got my
beekeepers hat that I you know when you
want to relax in the jungle
um you throw that beekeepers out so it's
your turn relax
yeah uh yeah don't like breathing the
air back in on me but hey I'll take it
you know and I've got my gloves and I
got the you know um the tips cut off of
uh um index finger and thumb and and
middle finger and so Ed's gonna go get
the guns
and I I've got my hands clenched hiding
those little exposures as soon as I
reached out to grab one of the rifles
um I got whack quack quack it was a
great day they are just honed in and we
smoked the area too to kind of try and
calm them down the idea was I don't know
how much would work but uh yeah legit
um not cool
so what happens you get done with apple
tune so
um I gotta fix my air you know and I'm
going I'm going back to Green Team and
uh yeah a lot going on in the household
of that time
um I was building a house uh and I had
Drafting and like a half a semester in
ninth grade so I drew the complete plans
to a house
um and uh
yeah
um not a great plan uh the house plan
was great uh the Green Team plan not so
much now not at the same time you know
her dad was sick in the house so we had
our first child
um you know was being born all the same
time and uh you know we're out at Shaw's
doing a CQB and um you know everybody's
taking a nap and I'm talking to the
plumber who's trying to put a bathroom
in the closet you know literally you
know uh you know
the city held us up back because you
know
um
the city employees disagreed with the
guy with PhD in dirt and said the septic
field had to be this and so it held
everything back and I'm doing this I got
110 days leave that I took to do this
thing and I'm doing it in blocks you
know I'm relinquishing
um you know what I'm doing uh at silting
for and uh
um
it just you know set a trip up do the
trip take some take two weeks to leave
uh and just knocking it out uh because
I'm talking I'm digging the foundation
I'm you know uh you know I've cut trees
down and milled the trees I built the
cabinets I built from scratch the
stairwell you know all the all the
cabinets all the window trim on the
second first and second floor
um it cost 180-ish thousand to build it
and uh it appraised for 720. uh sold at
the next year when I'm up in uh
um or several years later
um so I refinanced it when I moved to
Maine because I didn't want to have two
home loans
and uh
yeah so I did the refi for 720 sold the
next year for 6 10. put it on the market
that day and sold in a day a half a day
um so it did very well with the house
but smashing everything together Green
Team and the sun you know Tommy being
born and uh
um yeah I went home to see him be
actually heard his birth over the phone
and then flew uh into you know make sure
everything's all good I was supposed to
try and be there uh but on the plane you
know pre-911 uh yeah
not a great plan uh
but it worked out yeah so where'd you go
after that uh sdv2 did you want to go to
STV yeah
we were told we were gonna be the
snipers for all group two and uh uh and
uh yeah you said you heard that too I
got to tell all the group two first uh
all kinds of interesting things yeah uh
you know sdv's awesome went to the sdv
school uh um which everybody there gets
qualified to drive that and uh even
though the plan was to be in the backs
just to get out of it and go do
something and come back
um but uh you need to go to the school
learn not learn all of that
um I did a platoon there you know the
war kicked off
um and uh we ended up no one from the
East Coast was going you know uh you
know we deployed with Team two and I
think they sent a squad you know uh at
four they sent a squad to Afghanistan
and no one was going
um and we went to Kosovo and we were
doing reconnaissance there
um that was some of it was a little
sketchy we're getting you some cameras
and do some things we were looking for
some specific people you know some of it
was walking around town plain closed uh
which you know we really hadn't had
anything at that point to just be a team
guy you know in a foreign country you
know uh that was easy enough and it
really just were you at sdv when when
September 11th happened
yes uh 600 yard line getting out of the
van at sniper School uh and that is you
you were going through sniper School yep
so when you heard that sdv was going to
be a snipers that for everybody you said
oh if I go there I can go to sniper
school they said you will go to sniper
school
um right away and uh that's cool yeah I
know I mean
sniper school I won't say it was easy uh
because it's not uh it's very difficult
but our workups at Team Four were
basically a lot of it was especially the
the basic Warfare part
um was mini sniper school
um really good marksman's really getting
after it you know the month of field
craft you know uh and then another month
of land Warfare and then you get it all
over again back going back into the
jungle
um that that field craft that you need
at sniper school was all there all the
math was there for the shooting it was
all taught to us over and over and over
and over again so
um yeah
a missed honor Man by half a point
for Sniper school yes
[Laughter]
that's a bummer
yep uh and uh
you know it was uh
yeah a little bit of love hate
relationship there because I was always
trying to get
um
the guys on the reconnaissance side more
reconnaissance work and and not STD
support stuff you know
um so
then I became the lpo for
all of it you know the whole task unit
and I had to shift and be nice to
everybody you know when you're you you
fight for your squad you just write your
for your potential so you were like a
ref Squad yes you were the lpo the recce
squad at first and then you became the
record the lpo of everything yeah the
whole task unit and uh that was a good
shift too did you guys go on deployment
somewhere yeah we went to Spain uh and
from Spain we went to Kosovo uh you know
for whatever it was a couple of months
uh just doing reconnaissance so this is
post September 11th post September 11th
so you're a freaking yeah chopping at
the black like I went back to team to
you know go help out where help was
needed and uh that should have been uh
where the war was uh and uh it was not
happen it wasn't happening for the East
Coast for a while the onesies twosies
um and then uh
then then uh a buddy of mine was running
the sniper School uh uh good solid Stone
um and he said yep you come here and we
will send you over as soon as an
opportunity you know uh so I went went
uh uh you know would be the Scout course
manager and eventually the sniper course
manager no no no manage the compound uh
and yeah first opportunity you know
deployed uh to Afghanistan took my whole
you know crazy sniper street with me and
uh 37 weapons
hey it's you know yeah you're you're
Mark 11 you mark 12 you're you know
you're you're 10 inch upper you're 16
inch upper your 300 Win Mag you're 50
cal Snappy rifle you know yeah you're
freaking Your Mark 23 uh yeah name
something else and would you what who
did you attach to when you got over
there Seal Team two and the CG soda you
know and I would just try and get out on
everything I'd get out on uh you know I
ended up and I'm doing a lot of briefing
too you know it wasn't as you know
cooler than what I you know was
expecting but uh you should have stayed
in E5 is what you were thinking yeah
yeah
uh uh it was uh you know um
but you know I I learned a ton uh and uh
you know it was a happy to get out there
and support and be part of it and uh
it's a wildlife experience you know
um but uh yeah I came back from that and
uh finished up at snipers did I tell you
what teaching folks and and you know
working with the Cadre that that's a
wild wild experience too because our
sniper school is is legit our sniper
school is awesome yeah uh and then
indoor snipers are awesome oh yeah no uh
you know Brian Sergeant came on board
you know uh shortly after I got back
from uh and took over the the uh sniper
school and that was awesome we just take
it took it to Crazy levels we were
getting some 100 graduation rates and
which had never been done before usually
lose 10 percent per the major grade
graded evolutions and how did you guys
get it to 100 percent
we learned how to teach better and we we
made sure that Cadre was on the students
uh you know but we learned how to talk
you know uh you know don't think I'm
being soft
I'm gonna tell you right now Brian
sergeants one of my you know longest
friends in the teams yeah and I know for
a fact he was not being something
he's not soft on anything no he's not
soft on himself and he's not soft on
anybody else so if he's saying somebody
did it they did it 100 and and uh yeah
learning learning how to talk to people
right you know assigning the right
instructor the right students and we had
the one-eyed sniper you know uh oh Adam
Brown Adam Brown got shot in his
dominant eye and what does this team guy
decide to do when he gets shot in his
dominant shooting eye I'm gonna go to
sniper School let's see if there's
trying to get his eye healed you know uh
and so we'd teach him how to shoot
left-handed hydro which became his you
know who's a freak of a human uh
fighting uh brain cancer right now
um but uh freak of a human and a crazy
instructor and taught the dude to shoot
iron sights left-handed
smoked it but he he cleaned the uh
um the shooting test for you know with
the scoped rifles both of them I believe
that's awesome you know you're talking
out to a thousand yards
um just pinging on steel uh it's
incredible to watch and you know snaps
and movers out to 800 yards with a 300
Win Mag at the time it was incredible
you know but but patch you know Hydro
found what what he needed to say how he
needed to say it to him you know uh um
and hydra's always
um someone that's on top of the students
too you know he's not going to leave him
and go have a sidebar with a couple of
instructors figure out what they're
going to do tonight yeah
um you know and and
the instructors you know a lot of them
really wanted to you know it's not as
hard as it was when I was in they go
yeah dude it's harder you're just
instructing better and uh so we
we made up the uh
um this test uh that wasn't graded but
we we're
under the training command you get three
strikes and I don't think that's right
for Sniper school because you can't have
a third third strike and a sniper shot
and so we had you know a guy that made
it you know his third third time every
time
we're made of an exercise
basically brief the students in the
morning hey pull your rifles out this is
what you're doing we're going to put you
in an urban hide and the base was
awesome the base worked with us so
incredible on everything I had a 20-foot
bullet trap made on a trailer a six and
a half foot tall I made two of them
um that you could back together get a
40-foot Runner
so I would drive around the base and
write all the SUVs worked out SDC sdc's
worked out
um where uh
they would shoot a blank I would back
the trailer up to where the blank was
shot and I would go stand next to the
Target and load
live round
and I would stand there with my binos
three two one execute and so we had to
have trust that student would not hit
the windowsill not hit the fence of the
tree that he was weak this was short
shots 150 yards I mean sniper easy shots
but not when you're under pressure uh
and uh not whatever you did the night
before the day before
but we wanted to be able to tell you
know uh Parent Command and say hey
yeah he did and he passed everything but
let's let's you know uh let's take a
second look at it he's not safe enough
to do this Evolution and so I don't know
where that went we did it when I was
there I don't know where it went to ask
where are you standing with your binos
is this right next to the Target like
like two feet away from the target yeah
yeah that's a high level of trust right
there yeah I did it all day
they're my students yeah right the
snipers are freaking awesome man yeah
and you're not I mean so these guys are
already qualified on the weapons at this
point
um they've got some stocks to do and you
know they got like 50 cal week to do
they're really qualified on the weapon
it's just whether the question was
can that guy
when we wanted to do it make the shot
first time every time you know because
that's what you want for our snipers but
they were my students and so
um
I had to have the confidence in them
that they would do it and I did and uh
it was uh yeah
um I don't know sniper school is you
know morphed throughout the years is all
kind of just about the same everybody
tries to take it up to another notch and
make it better you're always fighting
with the Parent Command that wants more
snipers through and uh you know but we
always do it without lowering a standard
yeah that
I mean obviously I I had a I had 13
snipers and when I was a task unit
commander and like what a blessing from
God to have 13 snipers in the battle or
Modi I mean you just can't it you just
can't ask for anything else so and the
performance was epic you know the way
the guy shot I mean I had guys take
shots at at enemy Fighters holding
children right you know like and and you
using children as human Shields yeah uh
and those kind of shots shots through
Windows uh through vehicle windows and
just hitting the driver and no one else
in the vehicle like just awesome
unbelievable professionalism from the
snipers it was just outstanding and you
know I always when you start when you
look at the schools that we run it's
what you talked about earlier you know
when you were running Mar Ops you're
like hey how can I take this next level
how can we do a little bit better how
can I get more people more squared away
when you look at seal breachers like the
teaching schools just awesome this
sniper school is awesome just the
anything that you take a seal and you
put them you let us run a course it's
just going to get good we're just going
to get better it's just constantly
trying to improve and that's such a
benefit for our community it's one of
the best things about our community oh
yeah the idea that
um
the peer pressure
that you're not going to let the
standard drop and that you are going to
provide something that they've never had
before and it I mean your reputation in
the teams is all you have I don't care
what you did yesterday you you do
something stupid today everybody's gonna
remember you for that you know and if
you slack off and you get you know um
you make an easy training for you know
jungle warfare
um you're gonna get called on it uh I
mean those trainings that we got all of
them they've all been taken up another
notch and uh you know the biggest
challenge is a leader is to make sure
they don't you know get out of the lane
too much and that instructor drift yeah
making stuff a little bit too crazy kind
of happened from time to time you know
um so you wrap up your time at sniper
School what's next
um
then I'm off to uh off to Maine ah you
finally get you finally get that goal
well I hadn't had Shore Duty in you know
what uh became 21 years a little bit
um and so uh and I'm kind of broken at
this point too you know uh kind of
weight gain you know couldn't figure
that out
um like how much weight gain I was up to
275 ish dang was that does that ish mean
283 it could be you know uh it I just
couldn't figure it out my gut quit
working the anthrax vaccine you know
that was a series of six shots
and
all of a sudden like I can have one beer
um and I really didn't figure it out we
all went
we all went on that the Atkin the
fatkins diet I call it you know um and
uh when we went to Kosovo and on that
deployment so I wasn't having any
uh gluten you know and when we got back
we went to What affected the the Atkins
diet have on you did you shred off a
bunch of fat we got crazy strong uh um
and uh I didn't know what was going on
at the time so and that was for several
months did you lose fat though
Atkins diet probably I just noticed we
got really strong okay
um I mean no real notice to losing crazy
amounts away because that's the purpose
of that I mean that guy Atkins made that
diet I lost fat we Grant you know we're
eating meat and fat not to say that we
followed it very strictly as far as I
mean the whole percentages and all that
um like for the keto diet I'm like a
keto Kook and I'm rigid uh
but definitely no bread you know no
gluten no beer no nothing no pasta
we go to Germany
um so you feel good too feel good okay
um and then we go to Germany
the D you know decompress debrief and
out comes the heif of icing
out for some pasta and beers and
boobling in Germany and uh I didn't even
make another restaurant I just started
going even and uh
um it basically shuts my gut down and
it was years we didn't you know I
wouldn't got my gut checked out yeah a
little ulcer in there you know
um yeah still straight I don't know you
know we couldn't figure it out
um and I just kept throwing up all the
damn time it uh and gaining weight and
I'm eating healthy you know I'm not
drinking I'm I'm working out like a nut
and I'm just puffing up the joints are
getting you know head's getting foggy
but at this point you're eating uh
normal food normal regular healthy
American diet you know meat and potatoes
salad you know pasta uh you know and
just couldn't but it's all healthy a ton
of fruit and what are you walking around
at right now Weight Wise right now 205.
so you want the US 70 pounds heavier
than this oh yeah plus yeah and this is
when you get orders to go up to Maine
yeah yep yep I was I was gonna stay warm
yeah yeah those extra layers uh still I
mean it's still strong
um but the swelling started you know
um with the joints and everything like
that you know it I mean I'm
dumbbell pressing 145s I mean I was
still freaky strong
um and that's that's picking up off the
ground sitting back and then sitting
back up again and sitting it back in the
racks legit you know press
um that's funny because I always drop
those whatever if we're over 120 they're
getting dropped I don't know maybe
that's just me do it respect to the
dumbbells okay cool
uh and no um
it wasn't until I don't know maybe so so
we're talking 99 we got the anthrax
vaccines and they cut mine off at the
fifth shot they never gave me the sixth
um they just stopped doing it because it
was causing a lot of problems for a lot
of people apparently it was a lawsuit
too um a lot of aviators had to stop
Flying
um but what it did to me yeah I don't
know I got it no factor I never noticed
yeah no so people are different you know
um and uh uh yeah it uh definitely
something there that caused something
different for me I think I got it when I
went into boot camp though in 1990. was
it is that possible I don't think it was
getting pushed then okay it wasn't the
same one that they were given the
farmers you know okay Dairy Farmers used
to get uh or still get the anthrax
vaccine but not apparently not this one
that's right uh and uh
once I figured it out a doc just said
hey why don't you cut gluten out
um and this is 2012 time frame so I'm
I'm walking around gaining weight and
getting sore you know crazy headaches uh
cut gluten out bam instantly lose 25
pounds no kidding yeah and uh kept on
you know losing a little bit then I'm
now my keto Kook uh I mean I'm strict
like there are there's no there's no
pizza night nothing I don't substitute
not even just ordering a extra meat
pizza and just scraping the cheese
pepperoni and sausage off into a bowl
and eating that because I'm known to do
that right there hey that's all to go
and that's good to go I know it's good
to go yeah I do the meat pizzas yeah and
uh you know with with a side of guac or
something you know butter in my coffee
when I'm traveling instead of MCT oil
figuring out your diet's huge yeah
um you've got to figure out something
you know I never stop working out
even though some things got you know
caused me crazy headaches I find
something else to do you know find you
know the Blood Flow Restriction stuff
um and some sort of suspension trainer
um that that will fire you up you know
you use the Blood Flow Restriction
Training that's the cat where's the
katsu right
k-a-t-s-u-u right correct it's like a
little system you put it on it's like a
really strong uh uh uh what is that
called blood pressure right right right
right narrow that squeezes hard and cuts
the blood flow off to your lip right the
idea is you cut it by eighty percent and
then you work it right and then you work
out with with 20 of the weight so you're
taking a load off your body but you're
still getting a hard a mentally hard and
physically hard workout so so you're not
causing all that stress and damage and
you're getting a legit workout I mean I
the thing I do is 30 minutes I'll do
some other stuff too like with with the
katsu bands you know you can do the
rower for 20 minutes legit you're
hurting yeah
um you you mentally have to fight to
Finish
um especially your arms because you can
arms you gotta want you can cut the
blood flow off you know your brachial
arteries are easier to get to than your
femorals for morals you should literally
can't cut it off with a real tourniquet
um but you know there's some training to
go along with with that of course you
know I mean just don't go ahead and
start you know
get cut and let flow off you don't know
what you're doing and my workout partner
is awesome Pat I mean the legit I was
his client first you know as uh you know
taking care of my neck taking care of my
hip you know shoulder rehabs hip and
knee rehabs and uh became a workout
partner
and so I've got a pro that brought me
into it uh the The Blood Flow
Restriction stuff and there's crazy
Doppler systems that uh a lot of it was
was pre-amputee this one system I can't
remember the name of it right now but
it's it's four grand you know but it
actually has a Doppler tells you what
your blood flow is you know he was
thinking of bringing something on board
for clients
um but you have to uh you really have to
know that it's okay because the pain
you're gonna feel in your arms legit uh
and you question it but if you have this
Doppler it says oh it's okay you know if
you if you do your capillary refill you
get three seconds on you know then then
you're okay you know uh you just gotta
know you're not it hurts but you're not
harming yourself yeah any workouts that
cause questioning are good you know it's
like that 20 the 20 rep squat workout
that causes questioning of life and like
whether you want to be you know I've
been doing that workout where I'm
literally questioning if I even want to
be strong if I even want to be a man I'm
just like well maybe I could just hang
hang up on everything just call it good
I'm just gonna become a whatever some
you know uh take on a different course a
different path in my life oh yeah so
workouts like that are good yeah no no
yeah I mean you've got to do something
that's that's like the greatest thing
about you have to have some little piece
of adversity you know I don't care in
Maine you got to go get the mail and you
gotta you know then it's really cold
outside yeah and you know we got
chickens or we had chickens I'd like to
get them again because kids got to get
the eggs you can come into the house
when you get off the bus or you can go
get the eggs and come in the house but
if you come in the house you're still
going to get the eggs and you got to put
your boots back on and in the morning
before you get on the bus you got to go
change out make sure the water's um you
know not frozen or and replace it
um a good little responsibility for them
yeah yeah but it's a piece piece of
adversity that's you know easy easy to
overcome you got to have something in
your life that that you know
makes you make decisions and uh yeah so
so going back you get this Billet up to
Maine which for people who don't know
probably why would you know this there's
a Sears school survival evasion
resistance and Escape School up in Maine
and it's where the whole Navy is it just
Navy and Marine Corps and then you get a
couple you know uh foreign Nationals in
there once in a while but they come like
for instance air crew if you're a pilot
or your air crew you got to go up to
this school and learn how to survive how
to evade how to resist interrogation and
how to escape uh I know I went when I
went to Seal Team one when I was a new
guy the first thing they did was send
you to Serious School great I went to
the one that's out here on the on the
west coast and very very good Training
very thorough training uh very cool
training but you ended up being an
instructor up there at that school yeah
and you show up there what's cool about
this school
kind of like being a buds instructor
which I was never a buds instructor but
you get a you get a glimpse into human
psychology that that you know I was
talking to Andy Stumpf the other day
he was like debriefing me on you know he
was a second phase dive and dive
instructor at Buds and he he could just
know when he's doing pool comp on
something he had all these different you
know he could just watch the way a
person's moving their body and know
exactly what they're gonna do oh he's
getting ready to bowl oh he's good he's
gonna pass out oh this guy's panicking
he you just see it over and over again
and so same thing at Sears school you're
gonna watch people from a detached
perspective because you're an instructor
you're not all freaked out or engaged in
there right and you get to see how they
respond and you get to learn how to well
the interrogation piece is huge as far
as human interaction oh wow everything
so we conduct training to 50 Below Zero
and uh just the idea of that for some
point and we we modify it you I mean you
don't just do the same thing right the
instructors uh huge responsibility
um and you've got folks that have been
Cubicle Warriors they're Pilots they
signed on to be a pilot or an air crew
with a you know a coach you see it
underneath oh they definitely like that
and uh
um you know you know you get some you
got some Marine Recons that go through
you know used to get sales go through
still do
um although we like we've talked about
they uh got their own course now
um and they're doing some things uh that
are legit uh you you know you're making
a snow cave and that's where you're
staying tonight and you watch people
and this one uh he was uh you know going
through to be a C2 pilot and he did not
want to stay outside that night and he
was trying to sleep because you have
these Adirondack shelters which is
actually going to be colder and you're
cramped in with all these other people
but there's
um it's off the ground and there's no
insulation under the floor so you're
just you're gonna freeze you make a snow
cave and you're going to be happy as
happy gonna be your body's gonna warm it
up you just have to have the confidence
to do that and uh watching somebody try
and slow roll it and I go hey
tonight you're sleeping here whether you
get this done in the daytime or you get
it done at night you'll be happier uh uh
I'm doing you a favor and you but
watching their their minds work watching
people try and attach themselves to
people so they can get through
um you know like because there were
still still Team guys going through
and uh you know people want to attach
themselves to that team guy because
they're going to drag them through but
if you can't do what that team guy is
going to do uh especially when you go on
two brand of Asian
um you know it's uh yeah it's it's wild
to see and when they are uh in the
Captivity portion you know watching what
happens uh you know either Diamond
people out then you don't need people
really get into the problem and they
really I mean there's a little made-up
language you know it's got like 150
words
um and uh they don't come out of
character at all yeah the first time you
see something for people because they
hide them they come into the back of the
building that students never see in them
in the classroom portion and the first
time they see them they're in character
and uh yeah it's it's what are you guys
doing the Eastern block thing still Yeah
man they couldn't get away from it you
know it's a vehicle
but it's like I was telling you this
before the wars going on right now I'll
tell you I mean uh the first when I went
to Sears school and you get you have to
turn if you don't get captured by a
certain time you got to turn yourself in
they put me in the back of the truck
they pull us out they put me against the
wall
and this guy's like to ask me a question
and you know me I'm freaking 19 years
old you know just got out of buds and
I'm just like you know what's this
dude's gonna do to me and I gave him
some wise ass answer Brock right he
slapped me he slapped me as hard as as
hard as he could right I mean look I've
been punched I've been slapped many
times but I've been punched in the face
this was as hard you know this was an
open-handed slap right and he did it
like three or four more times and I was
like okay I guess I'm gonna have to
freaking chill out a little bit because
my bro right here is gonna be ready to
get it on yeah uh basically if you're
getting some extra treatment then
um then you're not doing it right
something you know because it's not
about being punk as well from my case
what I was not doing right was I was not
being humble and respectful and treating
the thing is as if it was real I was
just like whatever okay
okay 100 I'm in there's you know the the
tough Marine mentality you know which is
good to have but you got to know when to
say hey that's not going to work in this
situation and using those tools and
techniques you know to
be polite you know and uh give me a
rundown of interrogation techniques that
you like
um I like the nice guy interrogator I
said I wouldn't go do the the the hard
side you know basically I taught the
camping part first you know and then I
went and did that deployment we talked
about you know I've never been away from
we get into that later but
um I I I like the simple
um Soft Cell approach just talking to
folks and it's really the way you order
questions you know that that read
technique where you really give somebody
a reason why they did something they did
wrong uh kind of give them a way out but
leading them to admit to something they
did wrong
um it's uh
that Soft Cell is Magic it's really just
a conversation because I'd be like the
first person that they've seen that's
nice to them after they've you know
um been slapped around and all of a
sudden you're being cool hey I
understand you you understand why you
know you've uh been isolated and kept
away from everybody you heard probably
the coughing you know so we have to keep
you away from everybody and we had to
take away all your stuff and uh you know
make sure you're all clean and good and
uh you know and there's purposely a
camera with a red light on it that they
could see and they're admitting to
different things
um and it's it's it's really it's wild
to see
um it's it's Way Beyond what a lot of
the instructors think it is it's it's
how to get through roadblocks how to
talk yourself out of a ticket it's how
to you know
um it's it's everyday instances uh it's
a job interview it's it's really sitting
across the table right now and thinking
slowly you know sometimes if I ask a
question I might swallow or take a drink
of water so I can think for a half a
second and and come up with that you
know better polite or answer it's
keeping that military bearing and uh
um not you know being
starting a fight you know that that's uh
helps you out a crazy amount yeah we've
had some uh pows on here yeah mainly
from actually I think all of them all
the pows have from the Vietnam War and
it's incredible to hear their stories
and what they went through right and
they came back and put injected their
Lessons Learned into the Sears School
sure and so that was awesome to get
those Lessons Learned and just different
breaking points you know how long
someone can take it and you know
everyone's gonna eventually break but
you know how much you know how long are
you gonna go and even when they break
they give bad information or useless
information I'm pretty heroic stuff
there did you say you went on a
deployment while you were at your school
yeah
um so originally I was going to go out
the door with Seal Team too
um and uh do my reenlistment there with
them uh and get you know get it all
happy and tax-free and
um and uh that got denied because I
needed there at the school you know
there's only a couple of seals there
um and it really you know there's some
Marines there too but then the rest are
all Air crew and Pilots that that's not
what they do for a living so
um and then later on you know I kind of
made a little bit of better stink about
it a little better sales pitch to go and
I was going to go on deployment with
Seal Team eight to Iraq
um and it was all worked out I was even
going to stay there longer I was going
to really do some things
see related there you know maybe not but
I was going to be in a desk unit and I
was bringing myself well I mean we were
capturing a lot of guys throughout
throughout the war and having you know
at a point we kind of transferred to
having RC our own well not our own seals
but other seals do interrogations and do
Intel battery and they were freaking
great man they were awesome yeah so it
was really good to have guys that were
able to do that kind of stuff yeah and
it's uh and I probably wouldn't have
been doing that but actually working it
out right you know
um
the pitch from our side of recovery
um but really I was just going to be
working with a task unit and I was going
to be an extra gun and uh work whatever
you know
um worked it out with it with the
command Mass Chief Have Gun Will Travel
yep and uh all worked out ready to go
so I'll get I'm on my way down to
Virginia Beach and the civilian Ops guy
says hey we have this requirement in
Columbia you know the the agency guys
got wrapped up down there and they're
trying to get them out
um and we need a Spanish speaker
okay uh uh so I was on my way down there
um
and they they got
um released that uh um
but I was already on my way down so I
went to go work with the front Teresa
and you know was attached to uh dead
South
um and stayed down there for four months
and uh that was pretty wild because I
hadn't been to Panama
um since it closed
um and uh
went into the dairy and you know uh just
checking you know some things out and uh
you know what you see a an entire boat
load of Gateway Computers going making
its way into the dairy and you can't
miss those boxes you know the the the
white and black boxes
um and then you see a whole you know
cayuka you know Dugout canoe load come
of uh empty uh El Panama you know beer
coming back out
um
a lot goes out of the Darien Gap you
know where where it's really a national
forest you can't go in there
um there's no vehicle traffic in there
unless you you know a narco terrorist
um and so yeah there's definitely a ton
that goes down there a whole bunch of
I'll leave it at different things to get
funneled through and it was it was
really neat to see and be part of that
and try and get the furniture you saw
online to you know help us out and keep
things from coming north
so and that ends up being your last
deployment in the teams yeah uh and then
back up to you know back up to finish my
time out uh at Sears School a ton
learned though watching the different
interaction with uh you know um the
Chinese that were down there you know
um getting their fingers into everything
you know uh yeah you know yeah I'll
leave it at that there's definitely some
some work that needs to be done there uh
you see then next up is retirement and
what do you plan to do when you retire
when you so this is now 2009 you're
going to retire or you retire yeah uh uh
Chris New Year's year 2009 uh start the
new year unemployed with a plan gonna go
whittlewood in Maine and uh I had you
know Nest Egg settled up I didn't need
to work for a few years if I didn't want
to you know and uh that never happened
um you know the calls started coming
um and I started uh doing some training
back with the teams did just Contracting
yeah uh um we're gonna sit X's work some
different training pieces ended up doing
some some research test development
stuff
um and then uh then ended up going to
Yemen
um uh not with the teams uh uh the
contractor there and you know
administrative the security guy
um and that was pretty wild because
that's that's the you know aqap you know
uh al-Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula hot
hot spot we were right in the hot spot
of the hot spot so really learning how
to use my words because we didn't have a
gun
and you've got your guy running around
blowing up our wells and
it's uh
the stories are pretty weird because
they're that dumb everybody's got to
understand they're all stoned
everybody in in Yemen
you know which is a hallucinogenic
amphibian amphetamine and they're all
you know in the city they start chewing
it you know about four o'clock in the
desert they chew it earlier than the
desert um it's got a whole bunch of uh
different fertilizers in it and it's
it's it winds them up a little bit more
and so you try you know we don't want to
get a
um doing everything at the same time all
the time you're leaving the gate you
know um but you try and get things done
in the morning because they're wound up
in the afternoon
and so that's different and we got three
different facilities we'll check it out
um trying to keep the oil flowing is the
job
your inner security is the tribe
and the outer security and all the
outposts are the yemeni Army and they
hate each other the yemeni Army has a
drinking problem they make their own
Hooch along with a cot
um and uh
the state department contract for Pilots
pilot training you will not chew cotton
while flying so that kind of sets the
base of that actually has to be written
in a contract of
um and you literally
we had millions of dollars of oil
production slowed or stopped because
they didn't get their tea and crackers
and literally because the driver guards
want the tea and crackers while their
cousin
hijacked the truck
that has a tea and crackers in it and
took it back to the town behan and uh
um we'll tell your cousin to Let It Go
and
uh and eventually just let him and Han
for a while because it
the sharing agreement gets pushed to the
right and they're not really losing
money it's just delaying it uh and so
you eventually resolve it hey we'll
we'll go ahead and give you money to buy
your own tea and crackers and we'll get
you know things going again eventually
they say okay and then eventually they
come around to say yep
um we're happy to get in the raise and
now we want our tea and crackers again
it's uh but you get run down in the
desert by a guy who just got his brother
got drone in the desert because he's
running around with Al Qaeda and his
brother wants payback or his dad through
his brother wants payback for for his
son
he wants his back pay because he used to
work for the Army
um but you know he worked for Al Qaeda
when he got you know got the Drone
strike uh and and he wants back pay and
medical benefits from the company
because he used to work for the company
also
but he was blowing up the pipeline uh
and the wells you know one day he got it
below the restrictor the cutoff uh and
so it wouldn't stop you know normally
it'll just cut itself off the the fire
um so you got to bring wild oil in at
like four or five million a day
um yeah uh there's a bill uh and this
guy runs you down in the desert
well there were a couple shots over your
head
um to uh just kind of chest bump you
know
um not really intended to shoot at you
but she was actually pretty close
and they outnumber us and they've got
better Firepower uh so you stop and you
talk it out you know and uh you know hey
we'll work on this and you know I I make
the fake glass in the air they look like
I'm looking for the Drone
um and uh my security guy
is like their cousin
you know but he's sworn to take care of
me and it's legit uh and there's two
guys with belt fed you know rpks and and
uh
[Music]
yeah it's you learn to use your words so
your school help with that and I'm doing
it through an interpreter too
you know um Hilo pile or Hilo pilot has
a stroke
um that works for the oil company uh
because they're spyler spiraling up to
11 000 feet to get out of uh
um the range of the fire because I'm
there during the Arab Spring
and um
and the guy has a stroke
um that later that day in the chow hall
and they come finding me you know I hate
Mr Ed
um you know uh he just had a stroke
all right let's load them up and uh you
know get one of our vehicles he doesn't
work for us he works for a separate
company
um that's not taking care of him like I
mean those people are taking care of me
and we're taking care of everybody
um
and so load them up take him to the
hospital uh I didn't go
um you know I just provided what he
needed and then uh the next day uh Mr Ed
they're not letting us into the hospital
you know it's for this free medical care
but you got to bring your sheets and
your food every day
and go out in town get the medicine that
they're prescribing for you and bring
them back
well that day
um president Saleh got blown up you know
and uh one of the shakes got blown up in
that mosque was in that same hospital so
that tribe took over the hospital and
they've got it's sandbagged in they've
got you know literally
um RPGs walking through the hallways
um you know times good times uh and you
know I'm I'm this 200 and uh probably 65
pound uh white guy at the you know
blonde haired guy at this time you know
and then
yeah get me this ter this interpreter uh
um and uh we're going to the hospital
and I said hey here's what you're going
to say you're going to say how I say it
you got to tell them that you're very
happy that they're there you're very
sorry about their Shake uh you know
getting blown up and uh we've got a guy
in there too you guys are taking care of
your guy we want to take care of our guy
um please continue to make the hospital
secure but we'd like to go in there so
we could take care of our guy also could
you please let us in
and it worked they were getting shut
down you know and would not be allowed
in so we go in there and it's a trade
they've got all these over pressure
blast folks that are just smoked um and
then this guy's in there with you know
had a stroke you know grown man diaper
and not getting taken care of and so we
get them all set they run out in town to
go get the medicine and and I stayed
there with him and they come back and
they call me up and said they're not
letting us in again
what would you do well we just went in
start all over again you're happier
there they're making the hospital secure
you're not really happy but you're
telling them they're happy
um you got your guy we got our guy we
want to take care of our guy like you're
taking care of your guy and uh up I
think you know then they come back in
and uh it's uh yeah the ability to find
something the common piece your guys
hurt and our guys hurt we're happier
here you know you're going through a
checkpoint you know man I'm happy you
guys here have you guys seen anything is
everything good you know there's
anything we need to be aware of you know
because you know uh
you're not happy they're there but
you're you got to explain that you know
get that
find something that that's in common
that may or may not be yeah build a
little quick relationship yeah
there's a ton of that yeah so how many
so how long did you do that Contracting
stuff for
um
it's just kind of continual since I
retired yeah you know it really started
working again for Brian Sergeant you
know and and he'd get me set up on all
kinds of you know companies but it was
fantastic you know everything from going
to the Olympics the World Cup living out
in town with the athletes and uh you
know as Team guys is you you're just not
a monkey you're you're setting
everything up squaring everything away
Way Beyond what security guy does uh and
making sure everything flows smoothly
picking up you know gaps without
dropping security and securities as a
civilian especially executive stuff
is uh you really have to have a really
you know easy but hard mentality at the
same time I'm trying to look like
somebody that that you don't want to
bother and you're going to go you know
bother the other watch company you know
uh because that one's not worth hitting
and at the same time you know they might
want you sitting at the table with them
when you'd rather not because that's not
your job but it is to them
so you got to make a bunch of
Assessments uh and uh you know
um yeah do some stuff you wouldn't
normally do but you do the assessment
and uh you know it's uh
really interesting super super flexible
um and it's you have to be super
personable
um be able to talk uh with you know
heads of state
um that these you know
top I mean I I've been to F1 races
um in the absolute most without naming
the company as good as it gets when
you're talking to some wild people and
you know they want to talk to you
because you're the you're the seal you
know and they're proud to have you with
them and they're showing you off I got a
job to do still
but it's uh so it's a wild mix and if
you are the grunty guy because I was
with uh you know a rock band and who's
really good people uh super you know uh
um
yeah just just that that was super
enjoyable but we got some
we're always augmented overseas by
somebody else and the folks that are um
augmenting us
um they just have this militant look
about them you know including having
sleeves rolled up and and uh like you
know uh even you know cargo panty thing
you know pants and stuff and uh that's
not the look we want folks in a lot of
ways to do overseas you know I'm making
sure the the law enforcement that's
there
um is uh
um
that they they and I don't know very
well so it's you know because I'm we're
jumping into a lot of things but I make
sure they they feel right you know uh
that they're not nervous themselves you
know if you're there a long time I'm
making sure the driver is the same feel
today as he had yesterday and the day
before you know so so that you know he
wasn't threatened and told to make a
left-hand turn you know when he's
supposed to be going straight uh it's a
ton of that I've talked to the clients a
lot you know to they need to build
rapport and uh and be kind to their
security personnel and their drivers and
things so that uh you know they love
them you know their family because
you're asking them to take you know when
I'm it's the deal is I'm gonna stick my
neck out for these people and risk this
father is going to risk his life for
these folks and so are those folks so
you better treat them kind and like
family you know uh and I know a lot of
these folks they use this as a you know
uh they're a bit of a prop you know hey
let's get going you know or or interject
here and there and it's it's
there's some you know some of these guys
are skilled sales folks and they're
doing some acting and you know you take
it on the yeah yeah but he knows that I
know also you know so okay it's uh again
it's a wild ride if you're not flexible
uh and you don't have a mentality that
can roll with it a little bit
um yeah you're not going to be very
successful at it and I've had some wild
clients I really enjoyed that part I
like taking care of folks uh and I'm
yeah admittedly I'm saying pretty damn
good at it uh because they keep calling
me back you know you know and Brian
keeps feeding stuff and I haven't done
it in a while I started doing a lot of
already you know rdt any research test
and development with teams and some
other fun things so yeah you know became
a firefighter you know I'm a volunteer
firefighter and all I was rather than
all the until we moved from there then I
became a uh Reserve deputy sheriff in in
Lincoln County and so you're so you're
doing some Contracting you're doing some
firefighting you're doing some Reserve
Sheriff activity at what point do you
get uh roped in to the political Arena
yeah uh and I'm doing all that and I
bought an excavator I'm uh you know I'm
grading driveways and and digging uh
foundations for folks um doing some
diving for folks I mean I've got all
these things going on I'm getting my I
got my private pilot license I'm gonna
about to start getting my commercial
license and yeah it's it's you know
14-ish months ago uh people have been
asking a lot for us to get involved for
me to get involved in the politics and
because things are going sideways and I
kept saying nope nope nope and things
got to the Head uh and they asked again
again I said no and and I tell a story
over and over my wife said yes you will
uh her she's been from and she was yes
yes yes you will we talked about it and
her being from Venezuela and it's seeing
that you know that that leadership Gap
in Venezuela you know caused it to
spiral down people don't realize it was
Venezuela
we used to get 17 of our oil from oh
yeah more than any other country I mean
they were they were uh a wealthy country
uh and now they are you know again just
like the the hospital in in Yemen uh
they had to go out in town and get
medicine and provide your sheets and
provide your food and Hospital there's
no medicine out in town now either you
had to go to Columbia her family's a big
part of it's originally from Colombia
well they escaped the Narco State and
went to Venezuela now they're fleeing
back to the Narco State they had to go
to Columbia to get medicine for her
uncle who was in the hospital
um and uh yeah hey we've got kids you
know we've got two in college and one in
high school
and they're why we're doing it we sat
down as a family we talked about it we
had to make sure everybody was was good
to go with it uh and you know to varying
degrees to you know um
what does my 15 year old know about it
you know he gets a large degree you know
he was since he was you know that tall
you know uh
um he was dead this is made in China in
it that's not right you know uh so he
gets a lot of things and he gets this
too to a degree my older Sons helped me
write stuff you know when we write that
pledge you know maybe taking ownership
for the condition of our country uh
because I have not participated you know
in this I've always served but never
this he helped me write that he wrote me
write my first speech doing right for me
uh it all comes from the heart and I
free flow
about everything because it's from the
heart it's legit you know this is not
what I would normally do you know
um I say it over and over again too you
know you got grade my church driveway
you know I show up there when nobody's
there you know and I grade it it's a
it's a steep dirt Hill and uh make it
all pretty again load my tractor up and
I go away before anybody comes back and
now I'm doing a selfie while I'm doing
it that is not who I am it is now
was there a straw that broke the camel's
back as far as making you say yeah I'll
do it but was the straw just your wife
saying you better do this it's all the
crazy divisiveness you know in in Seer
school you know we actually taught
um how not to get indoctrinated and not
how not to allow these divisions happen
while you're a captive you know in in
the Korean War there were 14 Americans
that were taught in captivity that
America is bad and they did not have
these captors convinced them to stay in
North Korea that's insane that's
happening here in America how many ways
are they trying to divide people whether
you're vaccinated and unvaccinated
you're taught you're bad and evil if
you're not vaccinated and you're TR you
know uh you are taught you know uh with
your deny the election or you think
they're we need an election Integrity to
take a look at the election you know uh
then you're a traitor to the country uh
you you hey let's just take a look at it
make sure the other people that think it
was stolen
um understand it you know I'll take
that's that that's an okay stand have
all this division in the country is
insane it's not comfortable
um you know I've complained about it and
uh
that's the only thing I can do to make
it right so we're stepping up and we're
definitely stepping up as a family my
wife is a huge part of the campaign uh I
mean driving force uh and uh couldn't do
it you know wouldn't want to do it uh
without family buy-in but uh yeah
um it's a legit push you know I was
gonna go get my commercial pilot's
license so to do one more thing that was
gonna be fun I enjoy flying that's on
hold for a little bit what's been the
biggest surprise about entering the the
political Arena
confirming all that divisiveness
um you know because I I walk up and I
will talk to anybody I go to these fairs
these
um
um all the farm fairs and all that uh uh
agricultural Affairs and I I walk I give
my Spiel you know I always start with
innate you know a retired Navy SEAL
because no one wants to talk to a
politician and I am definitely not that
uh so I said hey I'm at the Atlanta
retired Navy SEAL runner for U.S
Congress uh you have time for you to
tell you about the campaign great and at
21 years of the Navy all the SEAL Teams
I'm volunteer firefighter and Reserve
deputy sheriff uh and never wanted to
run for office I'm running because I was
asked to and uh the guy goes oh hey that
that sounds great
um who's the president of the United
States you know
you don't have to like it but Joe Biden
is the president of the United States
and uh you know he asked me you know was
the election stolen again and uh I go
hey we need to work on Election
Integrity so everybody's comfortable
with the results of the election you
know whatever happened
everybody denies that the election you
know Hillary Clinton uh you know is
still denying that her uh election was
legitimate you know the hanging Chads in
Florida all that stuff uh we got to have
something that man called me a traitor
volunteer firefighter Reserve deputy
sheriff 21 years in the SEAL Teams I
want to get check the election Integrity
so everybody's comfortable and I'm a
Trader not cool that so a lot of that uh
you know uh building the campaign is
pretty wild uh you know we're definitely
money of visits Maine it doesn't stay
there so we don't get you know the
donations are don't flow in although
we're working our tail off we're out
raising you know somebody's been in uh
DC for 14 years uh they've been in
politics for 30 plus years and we're out
raising our three to one in human money
but she gets 91 from Pax and you know so
she's got smokiness and wow
um you know and mostly out of state uh
uh that's that's a wild thing you know
because you can look at all that stuff
in the FEC website uh that was a second
quarter 500. that's got to be uh like
just so crazy to think if you live in
Maine which obviously I got companies up
in Maine yeah yeah but you know but and
I don't live there but if you live in
Maine and you think that the people that
are trying to get someone elected don't
live in Maine and have no interest in
Maine but they want to want to change
what people are going to vote for that's
kind of crazy right yeah and I don't
know the right answer to fix that you
know uh and that was actually started by
a republican you know uh the Super PAC
thing which is you know they can do
unlimited expenditures in your name it's
no definitely not right
um and I you know I'm definitely the
weirdo I'm gonna probably go a lot
um learning about who I am also because
I've never put full thought into all
these ideas that conservatives have and
now I have to because it comes out of my
mouth and uh and it's on film or
recorded forever and so you know and
it's also you really have to think about
you know just like when I was in a
platoon and I became the the recce guy
you know Squad and now I'm the task unit
you know over the whole task unit those
are all my folks now you know um so now
I'm I'm representing all of district one
and I will uh represent district one so
I got to think about you know what
what's going to be right for everybody
and and uh you know I'll admit default
I'm not you know that's how we fix
things that's how we fix things in the
teams and military if you can't say hey
um let's let's look at the result of
that and uh
oh that might have not been the right
thing you're going to keep going going
down there and we're politicians never
do that they never admit to wrong uh I'm
I'm not that guy I am not polished uh
but I've never run for office you'll
notice I um and you know and uh hey Jack
uh but I'm honest uh and I'll keep my
Integrity you know I'll keep what my you
know my beliefs and uh
learning a lot about you know um me is
is part of it because you really have to
think
um
your decisions are going to weigh in you
know and make affect lives yeah it's
crazy with the politicians the
um number one to come out and say hey
this is this is the right answer about
whatever didn't say about anything right
and anything like this is the right
answer this is what we need to do and
then it doesn't work out as good as they
thought it would or maybe it's even bad
or whatever but instead of saying hey
you know what that is what I thought we
should do it turns out there were some
other factors that were involved and
here's some adjustments we need to make
instead they just ride that parachute
into the ground right like hey this is
the plan I came up with we're sticking
with it and even when you come up with
something I've been in leadership
positions for a long time now I mean I
guess for at least 25 years or something
like that I'm in leadership positions
and
to to to say hey this is a hundred
percent right everyone else should be
quiet it's such a bad move yeah because
the chances that you're so smart or that
I'm so smart that I'm gonna figure out
the best way to conduct this operation
I'm going to figure out the best
solution to this business problem we're
having or I I'm gonna come up with the
the problem solving move over here the
chances that I am just so smart that I
figure it all out no one else can figure
it out but I figured all out and by the
way when I figured out I calculate all
the variables in the future right that's
what I'm I'm so smart that I figure out
all the future variables and I get I'm
going to get all those right as well
that's how smart I am
so why would you make statements that
you're 100 right about anything it's a
dumb move and then when you're not which
is okay right why would you not say hey
you know what here's what I thought was
going to happen here's the plan we went
with because of that's what I thought
and that was the consensus and then it
was wrong and here's the adjustments
we're gonna make
big deal right no big deal I've worked
for bosses and I know you've worked for
bosses that pretended like or thought
that they had the 100 solution
and and then they won't
back down from their decision even when
it's wrong and you they think their
respect is going to go down that people
respect them less if they say hey I was
wrong but it's absolutely the opposite
is true when I say hey I screwed this up
people go Okay police Choco's humble
enough to admit that he was wrong and
he's gonna make some adjustments now
nothing wrong with that we haven't
politicians have not learned that lesson
yet right it's it's
fear of the sound bite the the fear that
you know well you should step down
because you made that bad decision no I
that was a wrong decision I admit it's
wrong we're going to move forward and uh
you know I'll I'll make mistakes and uh
I'll admit it and we'll figure something
out to find what's better but that's not
happening right now no uh it's not
happening and it's got to you know if
anybody thinks it was okay to mask kids
up
um that are you know born when this
thing started and uh they've never seen
a human face except their parents for
two plus years that's insane yeah that
hey uh you know the developments you
know been slowed down in all our
children and uh was that really worth it
you know was that worth uh shutting down
businesses you know uh you know we got
uh folks that that their business were
shut down and they sold out and they're
never going to open them back up again
and uh was that really worth it you know
well saying that everybody can go to
work in the big box stores and and
you're actually having more people in
The Big Box store hours is that right
you know um instead of spreading it out
to all the other stores while keeping
them because that's that's a human
that's that's that individual's decision
yeah and you go look sometimes you're in
a you're in a scenario you don't know
what's going to happen like hey there's
a bunch of people dying in Italy okay
well we're gonna lock some stuff down
here
okay well okay got it
and then like a few weeks go by and then
a month goes by and you say hey it seems
like in other areas of the world this
isn't that bad and and all of a sudden
you can't no one says hey we need to
adjust our thought process right now
right we made some rash decisions early
on because we didn't know what was going
on and you know if if you're my boss and
you make a rash decision
because you don't know what's going on
and I don't know what's going on I go
okay well hey man I'm good let's give it
a try because no one knows what's
happening let's err on the side of
safety
but then when you start seeing you know
other information come in and you say
wait a second this doesn't seem like
it's as bad and we had people just
holding the line on stuff that didn't
make any sense I mean there's some kind
of a is there something in California
going on right now where
the Indian casinos
stayed open
and the other casinos are mad I I I
don't know if not know enough about a
talk about because I I saw an
advertisement or read an advertisement
about it but the the other casinos are
mad that they were open
and that they were able to make money
they said they profited when when the
other Casino shut down and I'm like
thanking myself
hey if I was in charge of a casino and
there was a bunch of casinos that were
open and everything was okay that seems
like an indicator to me that maybe it's
okay like when we had the Super Bowl in
Los Angeles California and there was 90
000 people in the right in the arena
and it and it was no super spreader
there wasn't a bunch of people
and yet they went back to masks again it
was like it's like you can't make this
up right uh the the
roller coaster uh of you know this is
you you must do this and then you see
the politician doing that you know doing
exactly what they said don't do yeah
um I was like hey uh you know it's uh
it's very disturbing yeah it's very
disturbing and and you know again I have
the well I live in California Echo
Charles lives in California where we
were like ground zero for the
politicians saying one thing and doing
something completely different which
you can you know uh Americans will only
stand for that stuff for so long and
it's actually longer than I thought in
many cases it was sometimes like hey man
like
I you know we
we had a revolution against England
right like because they raised the taxes
two cents on our bushels of tea and
we're like all right you know what
that's enough we're done you know yeah
and and so there's only so much
Americans can take I think they
definitely got pushed to the limit of
that they took more than I thought you
know especially as time dragged on but
uh but what's what's really disturbing
is just the decisive the decisive
divisiveness that you mentioned already
where it's like well it doesn't seem
like in retrospect that putting masks on
little kids was a good idea
for two years right and inside of people
going yeah that definitely seems like it
was a bad idea and we should try and
learn from that in the future instead
they're like no
right no you're like hey man what
reality are you in right what reality
are you in well watching them you know
from afar dump sand in you know the
skate parks California you know put two
by fours across basketball hoops and uh
I was uh up in in Baxter State Park you
know it's a 13-mile ski uphill to get
where you can stay and sleep for uh take
a break and then it's another three
miles up much steeper terrain to where
you're gonna start to do actual you know
um ice climbing and all that so we made
it 16 miles in uphill
there's nobody in the park you know it's
uh that's the cool thing about Baxter is
in the winter is you cannot drive in
there uh you've got you've got very
limited people and they only allow so
many people in there we're away from
everybody
park ranger comes up very sad
you have to go home now we just made it
here
there's nobody there's nobody within you
know 50 miles from us
um I mean you know uh and so we had to
you know ski out of uh uh you know back
down the hill of the mountain and uh
that was so insanely disturbing and it
came down from a secretary of state I
believe is what it what they said uh and
uh that was so we were isolated we were
away from everybody you know a lot of
this has to do with the ecosystem that
uh that a and really the digital
ecosystem that a human being lives
within right because
I I know people that were in the
ecosystem of
you know covid was the most heinous
disease that ever came to the world
and these are these are people that are
friends that I know are normal like
logical people but they're they're
digital ecosystem the the word inside
there the truth inside that digital
ecosystem was just so closed loop right
that there was no other perspectives
coming in whatsoever and it was very it
was very disturbing to see to see people
that their world was so closed loop
that they couldn't comprehend another
Viewpoint at all and part of that
ecosystem was to protect itself from
outside thought and so anybody that
offered some other perspective was
immediately attacked right it wasn't a
car you couldn't have a conversation
with someone in that other ecosystem you
couldn't have a conversation with them
about it because they would they would
go on the attack and they would utilize
the truths in air quotes the right the
supposed truths from inside their
ecosystem which they truly believed
right that that they were true and it
was it was it was honestly it was it was
very sad to see it was very sad to see
people going through that and you know I
would try and address it a little bit
with people you know
um maybe mention to them something from
the from outside their closed loop
and and they would go on the attack and
and go super defensive and it wasn't
worth it you know I want to maintain a
relationship with a person that I've
known for 10 years or 12 years or 20
years you know you they're your friend
and I'm not I don't want to fight with
them over this thing it's like okay if
you want to continue to live like
literally quarantine yourself inside
your house
and we and we you know we met at an
outdoor place to say hi
and just mentioning that you know well
hey just so you know like I'm training
Jiu Jitsu right and I've been training
Jiu Jitsu with my friends and and all
the time and like none of us are sick
and everyone's okay and and and just to
see the look of horror in their eyes
almost as if
you know I was one of the worst human
beings ever
it was really sad it was sad to see but
again I think a lot of it
has to do with you know you got to open
up your perspective you know you got to
open up your perspective and you gotta
you gotta listen to more than one
more than one ecosystem of information
otherwise you're not seeing everything
and look you can go far to the other
side of the spectrum as well right and
and you can get just as wrapped up in
that ecosystem where you don't listen to
anybody else so it's it's a very strange
time and I think you know
um I always find that people run into a
problem with their ego right same thing
we just talked about if I'm a politician
my ego won't allow me to say I was wrong
my ego won't allow me to say hey I don't
know what to do but this is what I think
we should do let's try this my ego says
no you know everything I know everything
I I'm not gonna make any mistakes well
the same thing happens when it comes to
processing information you get your root
idea that you believe right and you
don't want to admit
hey you know what I was actually wrong
about that that's that was actually that
wasn't a good idea or you know what
that's what I thought a month ago and
clearly there's new information that I
should process and pay attention to and
people just unfortunately aren't
thinking that way anymore and it's like
this weird tribalism that that takes
hold that's yeah it's crazy it's gonna
be Rwanda dude uh you know you have to
know somebody to actually know that
they're different than you yeah and uh
that didn't go very well you know I mean
they had to know each other what's going
on with the lobsterman up in Maine dude
I tell you what just because I look this
is such a huge deal in Maine what is
this a two billion dollar industry in
Maine two billion dollars yeah two
billion dollar industry this is you know
when you think of Maine you think
lobster right of course hey I hope you
think origin USA I hope you think about
making jeans right 100 I hope you're
thinking about boots I hope thinking
about the best Jiu Jitsu Gis in the
world you're going to think about that
stuff too but before that I have to
admit you're thinking about Lobster
because Maine is the is the is the the
epicenter of lobster it's the it's life
in Maine yeah and so what is going on
yeah nobody no one wants a Massachusetts
or Canadian Lobster yeah I've never seen
an advertisement for fresh fresh
Massachusetts lobster right no they want
Maine lobster no offense to
Massachusetts no offense to Canada but
you want Maine Lobster so they're coming
up with all these ideas uh um you know
the right whale up there
um which is not even in the main Waters
they haven't seen it um and it's they
had an entanglement uh hold on I'm just
going to clarify this so it's called The
Right Whale this is right this is a
breed of whale right called The Right
Whale yeah it writes itself when it dies
um it writes itself in the water and uh
uh it floats so you know if they're a
whole bunch of dead right whales they're
gonna all be floating you know they
actually you know history
um they used to
um chunk it up you know and bring it on
the ship in pieces because it would be
just floating there uh and uh that
that's the other part of the one of the
parts of hey it doesn't make sense what
you guys are talking about
um
they're coming up with all these ideas
to to
you know save the right whale but
they're looking at the lobsterman a
lobsterman not the problem you know
everything from from the size of the
pectoral Fin and they don't have a notch
in it where you know the humpback whale
has a notch and a huge pectoral fin that
would get caught in a horizontal rope
um all these things they want to do
don't need to be done it's ship strikes
that kills them and it's it's Canadian
snow crab gear that that does it the the
main lobstermen have done all these
things to take care of it and get it out
of the way and some of the things that
they do for instance is they put like
breakaways in the lines right so if I
was a right whale and I got caught up in
a main lobsterman's line right it's
designed to break right and I get out
and I'm fine and you're good and they've
already done that they've already done
that well all the ropes are all
identified so if it does get caught in a
uh
um main lobsterman gear it's identified
as main lobster gear uh and they put
several breaks in it
um it's it's all been done and taken
care of and it really was hasn't been a
problem ever uh
but the the uh National marine fisheries
services
they made a decision that if a whale
dies in Canada
we take credit for it or half credit for
it
so one died there and we're getting
blamed and we're going to shut down our
industry and no one made no they're
under Noah right we'll explain what Noah
is yeah no AAA yep uh National
oceanographic
Atmospheric Administration and uh you
know it's everything from mapping and
weather uh in the ocean and they have
subcategories and one is uh National
Marine uh Fisheries services and they
came up with this uh
study
you know and if there's cryptic deaths
so if they get one death they assume
there's three more even though these
things are going to float and they
stopped they had they had Crews that
were uh
um detanglement Crews where they disband
them all because they're now
entanglements they had uh you know
observers out there they don't have any
observers anymore because they're not
there but still they're trying to get
them to modify things in a manner that
will shut the industry down so give me
an example of what they what the NOAA
the NOAA what do they want to modify for
the lobsterman
um they wanna they're they're really
trying to get them to bite in and weigh
in on the decisions that are going to
harm them so closures of you know the
prime areas uh
um so same areas of where you drop
Lobster pots right and catch lobsters
they want to shut them down they want to
shut them down they want to try rope
gear which is you know in the short
remote control buoy pops up from the
trap and you've got 10 to 20 traps
strung out and you're going to count
that this
um you know you're dropping it in No
One's Gonna know where the the traps are
because they you know you might drop
them into six knots of current uh in a
string and they're gonna drop 150 feet
uh you know you know even even further
and how much does a a lobster trap with
some kind of a radio or activated or so
it was must be sonar activated you get
the buoy to pop up yep it's gonna you
know whatever they end up doing uh uh
it's uh they're about four grand
um a regular Lobster buoy ten bucks so
who's gonna be able to do that you know
it's going to be big giant you know uh
uh
um you know uh Big Box store Walmart you
know China taking over our Lobster
industry can't happen because regular
mom and pop can't do that you know
absorb that cost uh you know it's uh I
mean we're looking at getting another uh
uh seafood processing plant built in
Maine instead of shipping it up to
Canada and uh that's you know uh just
like the oil industry they're not going
to build you know uh another Refinery
because they can't have a guarantee that
you know the oil industry is going to be
around you know uh just so they're not
building that um
your seafood processing plant there's a
whole other you know slew of jobs in the
construction and run into that that are
gone uh it's uh
it's going to have a crazy ripple effect
uh across Maine when you people come
there you know uh you know to go to
Red's eats and and stand an hour and a
half in a line to go eat you know a
lobster roll yeah this is like I said I
mean when you think of Maine you you
think of lobster 100 yeah so to shut
this down would be insane so what what
will you be able to do when you're
elected well one you know the voice
it has to come out loud you know uh
we're going to look at uh you know
cutting funding uh you know for for the
peace that's that's causing the problem
uh they got a job to do I got it uh but
if they're looking at it and if they're
looking at the lobstermen and they're
not looking at where they need to look
um then they're killing right whales by
by you know accusing the lobstermen of
being the culprit you know you've got to
once you focus in on one thing you're
not looking to take care of the problem
you know the uh it's ship strikes uh and
a lot of pleasure crafts and folks
trying to get too close to the whales uh
but it's it's it's not the main
lobsterman it's uh snow crab uh traps
way up in Canada and you know we get
accounted for like I said earlier uh uh
death there
um to
that's insane and that's that's America
doing it that's Noah that's a national
Marine fishery Services doing that why
why is this happening okay so if I'm
let's say let's say I'm let's say I'm I
love animals which I do let's say I love
whales which I guess I kind of love
whales I mean whales they're cool whales
are cool animals I mean I can I can see
them from my house and it's awesome you
know I look out and we can see them
spraying and we see they they come
they've come pretty close to the lineup
sometimes surfing wow pretty awesome
yeah
um so let's say I I do whales are
awesome I want to protect whales and
then I start going oh well maybe these
lobster traps could kill them and that
seems bad and then I start doing the
research and I see that they can break
out of the lines if they get tangled
because we put this into place I see
that they're counting what'd you say
mystery deaths cryptic they call it
cryptic death so if there's they find
one dead they say there's three more
okay so now I say I've got I'm I'm
multiplying when I start pulling running
the numbers on this it doesn't make any
sense to do that because this whale
floats so why would we say that it's
dead
so as I started looking at this I start
saying look this doesn't seem like it's
a problem let's focus on you know some
other issue because apparently the
because it's it is apparent that the
lobster traps and the lobster men are
not the problem
so
why are they not making this connection
why are they continuing to go down this
path which there's evidence clear
evidence that this isn't a problem well
because you can't have windmills where
you're lobstering and they want to put
windmills in those areas and uh hey if
they make sense cool uh right now they
do not make sense and you don't make up
a lie you know even even if it's right
the Owen Mills but your makeup are
polite to make it happen that's wrong
you're saying that the reason that they
want to do this is to because they can
put windmills out there like yeah can I
say that 100 because
um but that's where they want to put
them you know okay so you're saying
there is a plan to put windmills yep out
in that section of the ocean and and uh
um it's the uh they want to do it on the
sea mounts the mountains in the sea
because that's where all the sea life
goes and uh because you put the shortest
chain uh on those these are three to one
ratio chains
um nine foot links you know and 50
Fathoms you know uh I think it's fifty
thousand you know 300 feet
um and uh that's gonna rake and destroy
the bottom and they're you know
um and then they're gonna run horizontal
lines
um you know with the power back yeah to
get it well to string these things
together uh and uh you know that'll
catch a right whale
um because they get caught in their
mouth and all the pictures that they
keep showing of the right whale with
entanglements
um you know it's uh it's never been
our Lobster gear it's uh it's bigger
braided line uh and not the problem you
know it's uh
yeah you got to really look at it it
none of it makes sense you know none of
it makes sense and no one's going back
and saying hey let's reassess this you
know uh it should have never gotten to
this point they're looking to start to
shut things down next month
you know hey we're gonna do a lawsuit
yeah well
is getting shut down who's doing a
lawsuit uh they're saying that the
state's going to
um uh the lobsterman did one uh uh and
and took it to court and it's um it's
all the cryptic uh deaths and the you
know we were us taking credit for half
of theirs they want a 90 reduction in uh
um in deaths yet windmills
you know the new vineyard Wind Farm uh
down in in Mass they get to do uh 20
takes it's level B harassment which is
that's 20 takes what does that mean
taking but by level B harassment you can
harass them and if it gets taken uh you
had permission to harass it so you can
you can stop them from breathing you
know by by not allowing them to come to
surface uh you can stop them from mating
you can stop them from Sheltering you
can disrupt their uh migratory path
so you can do all that to the whales the
the windmills can
because they're they're going to do some
blasting they've got to do some Sonic
testing
um just the vibration of the you know
what what is the windmill itself gonna
do uh and if you multiply that times all
the windmills up and down the coast
that's more
right whales than are alive as they
count them you know so again it doesn't
make sense it's not about the lobsterman
you know uh take a look at it uh and
everybody jump on board you know uh
because you know they're
you know
it's so frustrating it and and you can
look at me as crazy you want because
it's that crazy it doesn't make sense
and it's moving forward
[Applause]
crazy that's why we're running yeah you
know because there's so much that that
uh you know we just gotta and I don't
know what I'm gonna do you know I I'm I
know I'm gonna butt heads my own party
too
um because I'm I'm that guy uh if it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
you know and it's about the country you
know uh it's it's never about your
platoon you're gonna fight for your
platoon your task unit your team but in
the end you don't do anything that
competitiveness in a platoon and task
unit
it never supersedes your your task uh in
the country you know I love the
competitiveness in a platoon you know
it's it's awesome because you're all
fighting you're all we want to be the
one you know when when the building's
burning
um you want to be you know the squad
that gets called to go in yeah and uh
you don't you know firemen don't want
the fire uh but they're all all the men
are competing so that they can be the
guy on the team that goes in and helps
right
um but you never let that
competitiveness you know it's like
taking you know politicians like taking
the fire and pins out of uh you know the
rifles so so that they they they look
better than the other guy you know uh
you know it's it's like a a sales team
you know
um you know cutting the cord to the copy
machine before the other sales team gets
to print out their their briefs you know
it's um that's the competitiveness going
on in politics it's
um I've got six years is what the what
the family agreed to is to do this for
six years and I believe in term limits
you know definitely self-imposed because
I got an awesome life I want to get back
to and uh
um
that's what you've got an objective and
when you when you transfer to one
command to the next you know you've got
a limited time there and you're going to
take that piece of string and you're
going to pass it off as a Repel line and
then pass it off as a Houser line and uh
you know you're gonna have an objective
at the end of that time that you're
going to be successful you're going to
have made America better and uh that's
not happening that's a whole bunch of
politician and a whole bunch of saber
rattling to get the next uh you know
election you know you know spun up fund
you know funded and everything else
um yeah finding that common ground and
and getting it done uh if they weren't
so worried about getting their next you
know uh seat in Congress the next term
set up they probably wouldn't be
spending money and sprinkling it all
over the place you know uh making people
happy with a little bit of money here a
little bit of money there hey uh you
know this party's trying to do that to
you and that party's trying to do this
to you
um you know when that's not true you
know uh you know definitely uh these hot
button topics you look at the mailers
that come in you know
um we're we're they're they're teaching
hate you know uh and these are like
mailers for different candidates up in
Maine yeah uh in Maine everywhere you
know we're you know the the uh
we even broach the subject because it's
you get demonized you know abortion you
know one side thinks it's a baby the
other side thinks This Woman's right and
basically
um that topic is uh
um either side thinks the other person
is completely evil
and that's not the case each side was
taught something different you know uh
you know Republican women don't want to
take away women's rights they're strong
Republican women and they they're strong
they believe in women's rights but they
also believe it's a baby you know and uh
um
on the other side they were taught
something different and people are
trying to make laws right now they're
saying they want to
but
it's uh
it's not legal to make a law federally
about it because it just got went it has
to go back to the Supreme Court and uh
um both sides are saying the other side
is going to do something evil to your
side well no you you actually can't so
why are you campaigning on it you know
and uh that's
I get
you will this conversation is older over
done when I say you know my stance on it
and I'm pro-life but I will not
legislate on it I'll vote no either way
it comes to me
you know it's uh I mean us saying this
on air right now is crazy questionable
because some people that will just shut
down
shut down on both sides uh you know
because people think I should take
my position and use it to what they want
you know
but it's not constitutional yeah so your
statement pisses everyone off yeah so
you got that going forward but you know
what I'm honest about it uh and it's
it's not Constitution it belongs to the
state that's how the country gets along
is we have all these little countries
that unified and became a federal public
and uh uh you know there's different
laws in in uh Massachusetts and
California and Maine and uh
um the people vote on them the
representatives you know uh represent
them and that's how we get along
otherwise we would tear ourselves apart
a long time ago you know and you know
we're not going back to the 60s you know
segregation and we're not you know uh
that could I get so much gets thrown at
me uh and I'm just I'm just gonna be
honest you know um it's uh
that hate that I mean it's hate uh we're
they're accusing
um one side or the other of uh you know
you know uh taking away women's rights
that the other side just thinks it's a
baby everybody knows his life
it's just when it's become human life
and we go so far left and right of it
you know
um
there's only three countries in the
world that uh
um
that have late-term abortion
you know China
North Korea and America
and again I don't care where anybody
stands at I don't hate anybody for their
thought on it I know that people have
been taught different about it
you know so
no idea if we should be going down this
route
honestly uh because it it's crazy
um uh I've been doing my Lobster Boat
swims did I tell you about those no tell
me about your lobster boats my Lobster
Boat swims so I'm swimming um you know
they have the lobster they had a rally a
concert on the water a lobstermans come
around and uh
the 60 degree water and I got my
campaign material in a dry bag and I'm
swimming boat to boat skinning it and
I'm hey I'm at the Lander retired Navy
sealed running for U.S Congress you mind
if I come on board tell you about the
campaign I hit 50 boats one day like
three and a half more hours in the water
I did it five times swimming with the
sharks
and uh uh and harps while the great
whites are out tearing seals apart not
this one uh
and uh you know I'm I'm campaigning boat
to boat again and uh you know it's just
neat getting a lot of love
um and uh
yeah hit the uh news guy uh he's on the
float and uh I won't say what channel I
really want to but uh you go hey I'm Ed
you know uh and uh oh yeah I know who
you are uh hey great I said you know uh
be great to get on camera
no I won't cover you
you know that's a crazy wild thing too
you know it never been done never has
that been done before and uh
um pretty disappointing you know that
that's yeah that's another crazy
disappointing thing is is uh that that
slant on it is is Pretty Tough well
that's a good way for people to keep
their
intellectual Medias uh loop closed yeah
yeah I'm just not going to put you on
right that's that I'm not going to let
anyone form your opinions about you
because they're not gonna Know Who You
Are
craziness oh yeah craziness um
so I mean it seems like that gets us to
present day we caught up right now
pretty caught up yeah yeah we're uh
running hard you know we're uh it's uh
you know I hit three four events in a
day you know I mean I hit three four
events uh before I had my debate the
other day you know just because I got to
get the name out there and we're you
know uh we're everywhere all the time uh
you know wife included you know a kid or
two once in a while and uh just driving
hard you know and seeing uh
and what what comes up and you're down
to the wire right now huh yeah we're
down to the wire uh got another form or
debate on Wednesday as a form I guess we
haven't Givens the format yet uh so
that's coming you know there's a uh a
third party candidate that just jumped
in September 9th kind of can't figure
that out yet he's a write-in candidate
that activates ranked Choice voting
um so you just vote at the Atlanta right
across all three slots
um he's the love party love over violent
Empire well I did say I love whales
maybe I'm part of his his thing yeah
it's ranked Choice poisoning it's
another crazy what's ranked choice so
you can put them in in order of rank
yeah the top person gets three points or
whatever so if if uh
if I don't win by 51 percent
you know over 50 percent uh then it goes
by ranked choice so you know you choose
one two and three or you can just do one
across for for one candidate and kind of
your ballots you know uh it doesn't give
any points to the other people how are
the polls right now the polls uh you
know it's the the legit poll we have uh
is that we're out raising or three to
one in Maine individual people human
donations okay uh the other one is
generic uh and it doesn't really take
into account me because I'm I'm still
very unknown even though we've been
doing it for 14 months it's amazing you
know there's you know a District's you
know three quarters a million people
Maine smaller being in their 680 plus
thousand you know can't reach all those
folks
um so we're out there we're in the
places that the Republicans don't dare
To Tread because you know they're coming
on board
um you know our first max donor was a
far left Democrat and Democrats signing
up uh
um to help us out why do you think that
is why do you think Democrats are
signing up to help you out as a
republican because people are tired of
what's going on uh they they want to see
change there's you know tired and scared
for the winter you know Maine is uh uh
fuel prices is going to be crazy yeah 60
of people in Maine heat with oil and
it's over double almost triple what it
was uh last year uh and and going up you
know um that's gonna people are really
going to choose between heat and heat
um and they were making that choice uh
before you know uh it's it's going to be
a very tough winner
um people don't want to be dependent on
the government but it's kind of being
forced on them right now and that's
wrong we want the Republicans we want
folks to be successful on their own we
help out
um but man it's uh it's opportunity and
freedom you know and responsibility and
people want that Maine is you know very
independent uh it's uh
a ton of the voters most of the large in
the state are independent
um and uh they just want to be left
alone and uh you know nobody wants to
pay taxes but they do and and they want
to work they don't get people working
again is what they want too uh a lot of
things have been shut down and uh
yeah it's hard to find workers you're
experiencing that you know working on
that founding some folks that uh been
signing up for uh some training by
Echelon front and a couple folks going
to the musters uh as I'm you know going
to the uh
um these job fairs you know talking to
the the not only the students that that
are going to some of these High School
uh job fairs but the employers too you
know uh um and I mentioned her earlier
uh uh the camper was rolling but uh yeah
the uh the Republican National Committee
um the executive director uh issues uh
the field manual
for discipline equals freedom to
everybody that comes on board uh pretty
wild yeah it's uh but
yeah people are tired people are scared
and uh you know what's in power right
now is influencing that you know
whatever side you're on uh it's uh it's
time to make them change if you want
change
because you can't keep doing the same
thing if things aren't going right you
got to vote it in and uh yeah you know I
do reach across the aisle you know and
uh you know I'm your your typical
Republican uh conservative you know
doesn't have purple hair but I talk to
them get ton of Love off of everybody
you know uh uh tattoos up to the
eyeballs I don't you know I'm happy to
talk to anybody you know um
you know cannabis you know uh folks uh
medically you know so on board with it
recreationally it's legal in Maine let's
tax it and move forward and uh protect
the the end it's you know those folks
are still buying stuff uh uh and uh you
know Republicans aren't normally about
that now I'm stepping on over the line
telling everybody right now I am uh and
that's not you know the Republican
standard uh I'm willing to say Hey you
know uh yeah I wasn't I've never tried
it you know uh um you know um not a
heavy drinker not never tried any of
that uh but medically I know it's helped
so many people
um and uh you know prescribe an 11 year
old Adderall not a good plan uh you know
there's other Alternatives out there not
addictive that they can keep them
focusing straight and uh we got to be so
much smarter about that so you so you
have different viewpoints from the
standard and you got an open mind
thinking about what makes sense to you
and not out what this party line is yeah
uh it's it's that's very scary Ed
it's the way I really lived my life
that's how I got where I'm at you know
uh so I've got along you know from from
childhood to now and uh that's what
America needs and he's somebody that's
gonna problem solve and get along and
say Hey you know um I made a mistake
there uh let's move forward you know and
uh you can't you can't not you know the
ooda loop you know uh for anybody want
to explain that
observe or Orient yourself decide and
act and then back to the beginning don't
just keep moving forward you know small
incremental decisions you know uh and uh
yeah but if you don't admit you you two
to two percent or a hundred percent got
it wrong uh you're never gonna improve
and you know do what we did in the SEAL
Teams and make such an awesome machine
our debriefs and the SEAL Teams are
brutal
brutal uh and uh they don't do that you
know uh well I'm gonna do that you know
uh I'm concerned I'm eating my own party
you know and uh uh that I'm Gonna Get
Along on a lot of things we'll see you
know
um you know and everything I say um I'm
willing to
yeah check it out and see where where it
really is
um I mean I've tucked on subjects that
that uh in this podcast that meh you
know uh people are going to say you know
crazy whack a little dude hey you know
what I'm still willing to look at it and
uh make a decision uh maybe say I was
wrong you know and move forward can't do
it otherwise
well it's a refreshing attitude to hear
where where can people if people want to
support you thelander for congress.com
it's
t-h-e-l-a-n-d-e-r or congress.com for
spelled out and and if people want to
see you uh after you get done grading
the church parking lot or driveway
that's on Instagram yep Facebook uh yeah
uh uh sealander for congress at
Instagram Twitter you're Ed for Maine
yeah uh Facebook is at the Atlanta for
Congress and you have a YouTube channel
as well yes we do uhlander
yeah Echo what do you got for questions
I have none no I'm gonna happen about
the actually you know so you uh come on
he needs practice he's got a debate
coming up so you're gluten-free then
yeah I'm a gluten-free keto cook wait do
you have Celiac because you were having
like celiacs so I got tested for celiac
uh uh and no
um not celiacs yeah no just gluten
intolerance gluten intolerance and now
I'm a keto Kook and uh where did you get
on the keto program right about four
years ago now yeah and and you love it
love it feel great feeling great I mean
everything's clear brain's clear joints
are better you know how long did it take
you to lose 70 pounds
um well first 25 was the uh
when I went gluten-free another 50 ish
um it was when I went keto and that was
yeah within a year and a half easy uh
year I mean I just it just came right
off and now you stay at 205. I I can go
down if I want to
um easy
um I just don't want to buy any more
suits
yes sir
yeah I got a couple pictures in my suit
the white collared shirt I got yeah it
looks like your dad's shirt
right on they had any closing thoughts
before you shut it down now hey um hey
thanks for having me on it's awesome
it's awesome to be able to get the word
out you know and uh Hey find that Common
Ground let's move forward and uh let's
make you know uh the best of of our
friendships and uh yeah we will make
things right thank you yeah I appreciate
you coming on obviously thanks for
coming out uh thanks your service to the
country to the teams
thank you for jumping into this Mayhem
that you're jumping into now and uh I
wish you luck in the political Arena I
just the fact that you can come on here
and and explain that you have different
viewpoints than maybe one side or the
other side and you agree with some and
you agree disagree with others
that's an open mind and for me I think
that's what it's going to take to get
our country moving in the right
direction so thanks for what you're
doing bro and thanks for coming on hey
thank you I appreciate it thank you
and with that
Ed D Lander has left the building
Echo Charles yes sir
are you happy you're not running for
political office right now yes currently
I'm currently happy that I'm not
currently running you kind of had a look
on your face during portions of that
recording that you are kind of happy
that you weren't yeah running for
yeah we're um talking beforehand and you
know you when you get into that Arena
this is what I gathered when you get
into that Arena you see the curtain kind
of gets pulled back and you see kind of
how things work and then you so
essentially you have a problem in there
where it's like hey we need to change
this how are we going to change that
well you know this system is set up to
allow this now that's really for this
but it kind of allows for this well okay
we'll change that then oh whoa but that
system has to be voted on by the people
who are benefiting from that system that
allows this
it's like oh man so okay what do you got
to do then then you got to do this and
you gotta and it's like this big like
unraveling of a thing yeah with like so
many unintended consequence and it's
like man it goes deep and then that's
that's on top of like the obvious stuff
I was like wow man I'm glad you're
running and not me right now bro yeah
well good on him I'm glad we could get
him out here
um because you know he's he's making an
effort he's and he's got a little uh
he's got like a pledge about taking
ownership of what's going on which is
sort of you know taking ownership and
actively participating in what's
happening with the country I can't make
that claim you know I'm attacking it
from a different angle which for me the
angle is trying to bring manufacturing
back to America trying to grow
businesses trying to improve our economy
through that methodology but as far as
jumping into the arena like him you know
respect so good on them uh I wonder what
because you know like taking
responsibility for a mistake it kind of
seems real obvious from the outside or
maybe because just because you talk it
all the time so now it's obvious to me
but I wonder if there's like some weird
mechanism in the political world behind
the curtain that
kind of like doesn't allow for that you
know like the the obvious not an obvious
one but the the one that just hit me
like right away was let's say I say
something dumb or I say something about
something that or make a decision that's
wrong or whatever they say well I'm not
like I made them I made a mistake you
know or whatever is it because everyone
will attack them like in the media you
know media Outlets have different sides
where they'll attack them
and then be like hey uh freaking Jocko
finally uh admits he was wrong no no
they'll say it way worse than that
they'll say finally confirms he's
inadequate for this decision-making type
or something like this you know I think
it may have something to do with do you
remember at the monster that we just
went to there was a woman that asked it
basically you know uh is it okay to say
I'm sorry yeah yeah I remember and you
know like of course it's okay to say you
know when you make a mistake you say
sorry apologize for whatever mistake you
made but there's people like there's a
whole leadership theory that you never
apologize
and you know so I think the thing that
we're talking about on the political
side I think there's something out there
yeah that's very similar never admit
that you're a never admit that you're
wrong right never apologize to you know
the opponent and you know like to me
it's the same thing you're just if you
make a mistake
apologize hey this is a mistake here's
what I thought was going to happen
here's what actually happened this is I
was wrong about this here's what I plan
to adjust for next time and I learned a
good lesson that I can confirm will not
happen again if I can prevent it at all
yeah so yeah I think it's just that I
think it's just and the other thing is
nowadays
I mean I guess it's not even that just
nowadays what is it gerbil said that if
you repeat a lie enough it becomes the
truth and so I think a lot of people are
just like huh you know I didn't say that
yeah no I did not say that
you know oh
um you know Jocko it said you do you do
you still
do you still uh confirm the what you
said last week about the blah blah blah
and I go I did not say that it was taken
out of context but even though I did say
it yeah yeah but you just said no I
didn't say that it was taken out of
context in fact that reporter has been
known to take things out you know you
just go in there in fact my opponent has
worked with that reporter in the past
that that's why they asked that question
because they're actually you know
nefarious and their activities yeah so
that's what everybody does everyone just
denies
makes counter accusations tells the LIE
enough time that it becomes the truth
and I think that's the standard
operating procedure
and I think most people don't have time
to pull the thread on it
I mean some of the presidential debates
last year were just ridiculous like
they're just they're just making
accusations and then not even defending
but just making a counter accusation and
just you know you said that you said
that the economy would do this I never
said that you're like what are you gonna
do go look up the quote no so it just
becomes two people just shouting at each
other
uh it's it's horrible the political
thing is horrible right now uh props to
these guys that are these these guys
that are stepping up and doing something
about it good on you
um and that's where Ed's at so
good luck Ed
I think he's gonna have a rough time
he's got he's got he's the problem he's
not a conformist yeah you know he's not
conforming to one side or the other side
right he's got one view over here but
he's got another view he's got one
conservative view one liberal view yeah
do you think because you know when you
watch it on TV that's like so you know
what happens he gets shredded by both
that's what happens sorry for cut you up
but only on because I don't know I don't
I don't know everybody yeah but I it
feels like
you know that I don't know yeah yes but
I feel like when you're kind of like an
honest person who's like oh wait like
I know I'm supposed to think this
because I'm in this party but like man
I'm still I'm still kind of like pumping
the brakes a little bit before I go hard
on it because I want to find out more
and oh I'm sorry I made that mistake and
hey this is what I'm gonna do like this
is how we're gonna fix this I'm gonna
say you know like you would think that
your everyday American person would be
like hey I think I like that guy yeah I
think I I think I'd really I don't know
him that much but you're probably
correct and that the extreme people on
either side were attack right but it's
the normal people like dude
cut caught him some slack you know he
said something he didn't mean and He
adjusted it and then but then they at
the same time they watched the news
who's like kind of like
hey if you'd use the cliche word
fear-mongering but it's like they'll
fear Monger you know they'll be like hey
wait this guy freaking is already making
mistakes or something like that you know
like they'll put it in your head that
this guy's unreliable because he made a
mistake and he even admitted the thing
like it's like he flagrantly you know
it's like that kind of stuff when it's
like bro you frame that as like this
kind of scary bad thing when really most
of us kind of think that's good if you
did if this media whoever the news
whatever if they didn't say bro we
would have liked that guy in fact we
wouldn't need that we need that kind of
attitude actually you know yeah so it's
like man we're all kind of getting
washed up in the Cyclone you know yeah
at some point someone's gonna break
through that has like a common sense
attitude that's what I felt too I was
like hey you know that's actually not
true no I you know what I said that but
I made a mistake and here's here's
here's a more here's a more a holistic
look at that issue yeah so and boom you
know but but again if the if the out if
the media Outlet is against that person
they're only going to sound bite the
negative thing the other day that's not
to mention you know how they say and I
don't know because obviously I'm not in
politics
at all but they do say I've heard people
are saying that if you go let's say you
know like um like Tulsi you know had
this happen to where she'll go in the I
don't know Democratic party whatever
she'll go in and she'll start doing
stuff that's like against quote unquote
against the party then they'll get
drummed out by the party itself yeah and
if they're playing that freaking like
kill them
game or whatever like they'll drama
person out who's like being all honest
and stuff yeah well tulsi's a great
example you know she got crucified bro
so it's like this hard-ass game to like
to improve genuinely you know holy cow
freaking I don't know it feels like yeah
I felt it though that I think you're
right I think like Slowly by slowly
people are gonna be like wait how about
let's actually like do the right thing
yeah how about let's just try it you
know a little bit you know some people
are crazy too there's like crazy people
there's there's people that their their
political beliefs are a religion and
their fanatical religious people
fanatical political people which to me
is is if you're that focused if you get
emotionally upset about political things
then I think you you should you got
issues right
you know you know what I'm saying yeah
there's people that get emotionally and
look I can understand you know you get
mad about something or
there's something that bothers you now
that's you know that's that shouldn't do
it like that right yeah
but if I'm going crazy about it yeah
like even you heard me talking about uh
California right California has done so
much dumb stuff in the last two years
and I'd be like dude are you kidding me
right now yeah but I didn't freak out I
didn't get on that's another thing if
you're on social media and that's like a
place where you're spending your time
flipping out on flipping out on people
what was it I think I was on that
podcast with Chris Williamson and he
asked me something about what was it
like how do you you know I think it was
it was basically either how do you
handle negative comments or something
like this
and I was like bro I mean my
recommendation is you don't spend a
bunch of time being concerned about Bots
bro they're bots so
I think when you're politically outraged
about something
because because here's the other thing
you gotta remember okay if you're a
lobsterman and you're about to have your
you're about to have your your entire
ability to provide for your family I can
understand getting outraged about that
yes I can I can understand being like oh
you know what I'm going to protest
because they're about to take my
livelihood away from me yeah
but there's a lot of things that people
get emotional about that actually really
aren't going to have an impact on their
life yeah you know yeah or it's like a
hypothetical thing yeah or whatever yeah
also too like um and then I don't
necessarily see people getting outraged
about it but but being like couldn't
really concerned about it you know on a
personal level is um the one that does
make sense to me is like the taxes and
stuff where like
when you know you're gonna get less of
your paycheck that makes sense to me
yeah you know yeah but yeah if you want
to make if you want to get even more
frustrated about that once you realize
that the government is taking a bunch of
your money yeah
and then you see what they're doing with
it and you say to yourself wait a second
bro like hey if you were building
awesome Bridges you know and the streets
were clean like Look at California if
you're like hey you know what I pay a
lot of tax in California but look look
at Main Street you know Los Angeles this
beautiful place but you're not saying
that you're literally it's disgusting
right it's disgusting and then they do
other crazy things so you could start to
get a little spun up about that but do
you know what you do then you leave the
state which is what a lot of people have
done how many people are leaving
California yeah a lot yeah that should
be an indicator and you could look at
the federal taxes the same way you're
like hey look I want to pay for the
secure I'm gonna pay for the military
right right that's cool to pay for some
infrastructure I'm good with that but
then when you start pulling the thread
on those things
we should do a podcast where we just
read through some of those expenditures
oh it's insane it's totally insane what
the government spends money on you can't
make it up if I tried to make up things
right now for dumb stuff for the
government to spend money on I couldn't
come close to the dumb stuff
the government it spends money on the
dumbest things
and and yet what are you gonna do
well you do your best to vote for people
that want to tax less and that want to
have a smaller government and
because big the bigger the government
doesn't become more efficient does it
solve more problems like when you're
going to when you're doing an operation
you're going in I had this conversation
with life life was like kind of in the
learning mode and you're taking down
buildings
and you think hey I'll just put everyone
in the building
yeah but you can put so many in the
built people in the building that
they're kind of in the way now you gotta
like hire someone you gotta Advance or
promote someone to be in charge of the
other group while they're in the
building and that means those two people
got to communicate so you gotta put
someone in charge you see what I'm
saying all of a sudden you've got a
bureaucracy in a in a kill house
we don't want that that's like the big
government problem you know a big
assault Force look you need an assault
Fortune you have enough people to handle
the rooms and handle security cool I get
it but you can't just double that yeah
and say okay now it's going to be more
efficient it might not be more efficient
and if you triple it you may have some
real issues now now you have a problem
and now the problem is the assault Force
itself you have a chance of creating a
Blue on Blue because there's so many
freaking assaulters going in so the same
thing happens with the government I mean
here's they just well this bill coming
where there's 87
000 more IRS agents yeah
I think it doubles the size of the IRS
that's too many assaulters in the room
you see what I'm saying like there's too
many how hey if the tax code they don't
even know really what the tax code is
you know I hire someone I can't figure
out what my taxes are I can't even come
close to figuring all my taxes are I
have to hire someone who's got multiple
people working for him that goes through
and figures all that out
because that's how complicated it is
yeah so I have to pay someone who also
pays other people to figure out what I
need to pay the government yeah
why it makes sense that if the
government is going to bill me for
something they just give me a bill and I
pay it you know I don't go into a
restaurant
order dinner and I say hey uh you know
how much do I owe you
and they say well figure it out yeah
here's a scale you better weigh that
race yeah you know here's the cost of
rice right now and by the way if you
don't if you don't come up with the
right number we're gonna have you
arrested when you leave this the
restaurant because you didn't pay the
money that you owed us well I don't know
how much I owe you well you better
figure it out yeah that's crazy what if
you overpay the gov like your taxes and
you like let's say you overpaid your
taxes and it rolls forward it rolls
forward do they do that automatically
though or do you have to like say hey I
overpaid and then they do it uh I'm not
sure but I know that my accountant
shout out Brandon good to go freaking
awesome guy
sometimes he tell he sends me a list
like this is what you overpaid and how
this got rolled up but I don't know if
he didn't do that would they just be
taking that money probably I wonder yeah
so that would kind of make it
like
officially unfair bro it's officially
unfair as it is
right I think you're it's officially
unfair as it is you are gonna charge me
you want me to pay you money but you
won't tell me how much because I got to
figure that out and if I get it wrong
you're in trouble yeah yeah how's that
work how did you know I was wrong well
why don't you just tell me what that
number was
right I gotta pay this other dude and
his team to figure out how much money I
owe you and if I don't pay you the
correct amount you're gonna arrest me
but you won't tell me what that number
was yeah that's some crazy talk that's
proof you wouldn't think that that made
any sense whatsoever and yet that's how
it works and now we gotta hire 87 000
more people 87 000 by the way when you
hire 87 000 people at the government you
when you get Government Federal jobs
like that that's a lifetime of pay
that's that's retirement pay that's
health insurance for the rest of all
these people's lives it's health
insurance for their families it's a
crazy deal it's not like
you hired a number a small number of
people and they're going to do some
extra work and when they're done with
that extra work they're going to move on
find another job no this is a you're
you're hiring someone for their life
yeah that's what a federal job is so
these aren't like small budgetary
additions these are these are a total
change
a paradigm shift in the size of this tax
collecting organization
and that's the best you can do
everything is digital now and the best
you can do is hire 87 000 more people to
help us figure this out are you kidding
me right now
so you want to you want to talk about
stuff that can get you crazy that's one
of them but but nonetheless
I'm talking about it right now with you
I've never talked about this with you
and I don't I know when I go home I'm
not going to be like fuming about it
right yeah there's issues that people
get spun up about and and by the way
what I just talked about that's a pretty
serious issue they're taking money that
you worked for they're taking it from
you and they're spending on things that
don't make any sense that's that if
there's one thing that could piss you
off that's definitely in the top seven I
agree yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
I mean would you be mad if I went in got
into your car took your walled out took
your money and left would you be mad
what if I only took 50 of your money
would you be mad I would be mad yes and
but what if I bought you dinner
with your money but I also kind of
bought me dinner too
so so people taking your money is
definitely one of the top things that
can be annoying to you and can piss you
off yeah the government does that all
the time yeah so if there's but that's a
top seven
definitely in the top seven of things
that can piss you off people stealing
from you hey look
it's only it's not stealing up to a
certain point because when I when the
government takes money and they spend it
on things that you know help hey okay
we're gonna have a good military we're
gonna have good infrastructure we're
gonna have some Reserve you know fuel in
case something goes though hey I'm in
support of those things cool I got it
but that hits a limit the government
doesn't need 51 of my money to do that
yeah
it doesn't but they're taking it
they're spending on some other
some some that I don't you know
that is not right
so that's where we end up proof of
yeah anyways you guys are talking about
the O course how you can't just go in
there anymore
you think you could do the oak course uh
right now yeah 100
no I probably wouldn't get a great score
because there's some technique that I'd
be rusty on is there a minimum you gotta
make or something can you fail the oh
course you can definitely fail to your
course would you fail to work
yeah would I pass it I would need to
teach it to you for two days and then
you'd pass it yeah if you're if you're
athletic like you if you can do pull-ups
push-ups dips and you can run you're
gonna be okay it's I tell you what that
old course is awesome when you get done
with that thing you're smoked oh it's
hard like oh yeah how long does it take
roughly seven minutes oh damn seven
minutes of pudding out seven minutes of
putting out hard like you know uh you
know the
the taste in your mouth you know what
I'm saying like the the I just put out
real hard what is it like a copper
tasting my mouth you know what I'm
saying yes sir you get that hundred
percent oh for real even if you're kind
of chilling like let's say let's say you
and I went out there weekend you know
we're in the teams and we'll just go out
there you're still gonna feel it a
little bit yeah but when you go hard
because you're trying to pass because
you're in buds bro you feel like it's a
big time Big Time I always liked the
expression putting out yeah I don't
think I ever heard that tell you hung
around you guys or whatever
cool well speaking of putting out you
got it you got a fuel yes the output yes
I'm not going to recommend you do that
with some clean fuel yeah
the cleanest fuel
Docker fuel it's true physical mental
integrity
like these are all important things so
when you fuel that you fuel your
integrity how do you throw that one in
there I got physical like I'm mentally
no no tossed Integrity no no no no no
what I'm saying you got a kid and
they're not they're do kids lying in
school we give me some Jocko fuel over
tight numbers
when you're putting out is what I'm
saying I'm gonna make a new supplement
called Integrity maybe you should let's
do it all right there you go book it put
on the books or whatever the expression
is you guys use anyway yes when you fuel
that output when you're putting out all
that stuff
you want the supplements with Integrity
you want to integrity means supplements
that's something okay energy for example
energy drink let me explain to you like
you don't know even though I do know
that you do know
energy drink usually have sugar calf uh
uh preservatives you know
poison right
chocolate fuel does not have that clean
only healthy stuff clean stuff yeah
integrity that's what I mean exactly
what I'm talking about same thing with
the malt protein shakes protein mix and
RTD no sugar
sweetened with fruit not even like a
sucrose or fructose or actual monk fruit
bone fruit so good so good uh yeah so
check the actually on the way down you
heard keto what did how did Ed describe
himself keto keto cook keto cook
I said hey man you want one of these
drinks he goes I can't it's it's uh I'm
a keto Kook and I was like we're good
yeah good to go he said there's no sugar
in there I said no there's no sugar it's
sweetened with monk fruit yep and he's
like oh cool crack One open keto cook
get it now ketoku getting after uh keto
cook approved yeah and she says what
does it say it says something on the can
about keto keto friendly Maybe
anyways
so there you go yeah get yourself some
Jocko fuel jockofuel.com go to Wawa go
clear the shelves at Wawa that's what
you got to do clear the shelves at Wawa
just go go in there to buy them all
that'll that will help the campaign to
grow
because people look at Wawa and they say
oh it's doing really well and Wawa cool
so if you want to help if you want to
help the campaign of growth go to Wawa
clear the shelves vitamin shop
pink mist is at the Vitamin Shop
pinkness has kind of been a big hit have
you noticed that across the board I had
one today and it's good it's one of
those like if you go to like it's it's
it's kind of what do you call it when
it's safe you know we're so you can't go
wrong you can't go wrong with that one
oh well that's how you feel a lot of
people a lot of people feel that's the
one oh no this is the time
Mango's the one by far my opinion but
I'm with it I'm with the whole gig Joker
fuel.com originusa.com okay so Ed from
Maine
one of the problems up in Maine
is got to grow the economy it's so if
you want to help grow the economy in
Maine go to originusa.com and you're
going to find just blue jeans that were
made in America that are made in America
G uh boots that that are made in America
jiu jitu GIS that are made in America we
also have another Factory down in North
Carolina as well
so American made is what we're doing at
originusa.com go and get yourself some
American-made
gear
and help America help Manufacturing in
America
that's what we're doing we appreciate
you helping us to do it and you doing it
too boom it's true also don't close the
store it's called Jocko store where you
can get your discipline equals Freedom
shirts and hats and hoodies and stuff
also we have the shirt Locker which is a
subscription shirt
every month cool designs no more
days where you don't know what shirt to
wear you got one don't you normally say
it's a subscription situation it is a
subscription situation 100 whether I say
it or not it's true chocolate store.com
that's where you get get the stuff check
it out if you want something get
something uh Jocko underground.com go
check that out we're putting on podcasts
on that and it's also a little uh
uh safe Zone sure was that safe space
you know what it is yeah we're safe in
there they can't take it away from us
that's true it's kind of not the the
typical term safe space no it's a
typical term but I know that freedom of
speech is safe inside
Jocko underground.com go check that out
YouTube check out that uh you want to
see some awesome videos that I have
assistantly directed assistant directed
yes YouTube psychological warfare
Flipside canvas bunch of books you know
what they are I've written a bunch of
books Echelon front leadership
consulting company we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details just got
done with the muster
down in Atlanta it was an awesome event
and you know what it was sold out and
everything we do sells out so if you
want to come to one of our events live
go to nationalfront.com and check out
the events we also have the online
training academy
so if you want to learn these principles
and you want to train these principles
for your business and for your life
go to extreme ownership.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help gold
star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and also check out Micah Fink
and heroes and horses taking vets into
the field
where they can get lost and there they
will become found once again thanks to
Ed thielander
for coming on the show and to follow him
or check out what he's got going on
sealanderforcongress.com the Instagram
is
the Lander for congress the Twitter is
Ed for Maine
Facebook at delander for congress on
YouTube at the lender and if you want to
hang out with me and Echo online in the
in the
zone right sure in the interwebs yeah
we're on there too Echoes ago Charles
I'm at Jocko willing just just be
careful because the algorithm's there
and it's not it's not for your friend no
it's pretending to be your friend
it's going hey look at this like it's
saying that to you okay you're gonna
show you something and it's something
you want to see yeah well it's something
that your most base form wants to see
yeah you don't want to see it you want
to be disciplined you want to carry on
with your life you want to go execute on
awesomeness but instead the algorithms
got you like an octopus
I think we need an octopus algorithm
t-shirt
a bunch of different things trying to
tie you up so there you go
thanks once again to Ed for coming out
sharing your lessons and thanks for your
service to the teams and your continued
Service to America and speaking of
service I want to say thanks to all of
our military active duty and retired
every Branch every rank out there thank
you for protecting our freedom and our
way of life and thanks to our police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service all First
Responders
thank you for protecting us here at home
and everyone else out there
since we were talking about Maine
I'm gonna go ahead and close with some
more of the great Joshua Chamberlain
quote
we can hold our spirits and our bodies
so pure and high we may cherish such
thoughts and such ideals and dreams such
dreams to lofty purpose
that we
can determine and know what manner of
men we will be
and that's right
end quote we can determine what manner
of men we will be
and we become that man
by taking action
so
in the parlance of our time
get out there
and get after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out